Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim Brittlov und ich begrüße,
zur 86 Ausgabe und heute ist ein Freitag und äh ihr ahnt es schon. Es handelt sich um ein Corona-Wiki, was ja nicht mehr ganz so weekly ist, aber äh das werdet ihr uns sicherlich nachsehen. Immerhin sind wir jetzt schon wieder auf Bye Weekly.
Äh das gibt die Nachrichtenlage her. Ich sage erst mal hallo zu Pavel, hallo Pavel.
Ja, hallo Tim, äh.
Ja da da sind wir wieder. Ich hatte ich hatte eine kleine Auszeit. Mhm.
Einen Bildungsurlaub gemacht und war in äh Israel. Da war es außerdem warm, das war ganz brauchbar. Ähm nur ein paar Tage, nur eine Woche
aber äh ich fand das natürlich äh ein doppelt interessant, weil natürlich ähm.
Dass äh vor allem für mich eine äh Studienreise war, um einfach mal so ein bisschen ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, wie so andere Länder das äh handeln.
Mit dem äh Corona und wir wissen ja alle, dass Israel uns eigentlich in vielerlei Hinsicht oder zumindest haben wir alle dieses Gefühl, dass uns Israel in vielerlei Hinsicht da voraus ist.
Bei bei Design eigentlich oder? Das war Absicht, dass die Israelis irgendwie quasi unsere Testkaninchen sind und äh.
Vorrangig beliefert werden und wir dann dafür äh mal gucken, was dort passiert irgendwie, überleben die Leute da oder sterben sie und wenn sie überleben, dann
machen wir das genauso. So das war glaube ich der Plan.
Das war der Plan, wir machen das auch genauso, nur viel zu spät. Wenn man das sozusagen immer gleich ein, zwei Monate sofort danach machen würden, dann äh wären wir schon wirklich sehr viel besser gefahren.
Israel hat am 1. August mit dem Boostern begonnen übrigens, hatte ich neulich mal nachgeguckt äh.
Mhm. Ja, genau. Gut, aber Sie waren natürlich auch früher dran mit allem, ne?
Ja ja ja aber äh es sind trotzdem irgendwie fünf äh oder na ja gut äh
Bei uns ist das Booster dann auch sehr langsam angelaufen äh äh irgendwann und läuft jetzt auch schon, was seit über einem Monat, sechs Wochen oder so wird ja schon geboostert, aber das ging ja erstmal sehr sehr langsam los bei uns.
Äh und eigentlich hat sich dann auch äh also allen sagen, dass ich glaube, dass das das Äquivalent zu irgendwie äh wie la vom RKI aus Israel, ich weiß nicht, wie er heißt, hat äh da wohl öffentlich Unverständnis darüber geäußert.
Dass Deutschland nicht irgendwie mehr oder weniger zeitgleich begonnen hat, weil die Israelis hatten zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo sie begonnen haben, die ganzen Daten schon vorliegen, ja.
Äh also es war jetzt nicht so, dass dass die Israelis jetzt auch wir probieren das mal wie das mit dem Bus dann äh äh aussieht und ob das Sinn macht, sondern nee
äh die haben halt angefangen, weil die gesehen haben, äh wie äh dass sich das mit den Durchbruchs,
Impfungen entwickelt und äh wie die Immunität nachlässt und äh hat eine solide Zahlenbasis und es gab eigentlich zu dem Zeitpunkt nicht wirklich einen Grund, warum wir nicht ein, zwei Wochen später,
auch damit begonnen
äh äh oder eigentlich sogar zeitgleich, ja, aber so wenn bei uns sowieso immer alles länger dauert, äh so hätte man sagen können, okay hätten sich mal zwei Wochen noch mal Zeit lassen können, um nochmal äh das aus Israel
zu zu checken und äh ja aber ist halt nicht passiert und insofern
Ja, den Fehler hat ja die STIKO jetzt auch eingeräumt, dass sie da ein bisschen äh langsam waren.
Ja
Ich meine die Politik war zu dem Zeitpunkt halt auch voll im also erstmal war natürlich Urlaub so und alle haben sich noch im August sozusagen die Illusion äh hingegeben. Das ist ja alles nicht so schlimm sein wird.
Äh auch, weil die war ja im Wesentlichen im Wahlkampf. Und gut, das haben wir ja nun alle gesehen, wie sehr das Thema Corona nicht im Vordergrund stand.
Gut, aber die STIKO sollte ja eigentlich unabhängig jetzt von Politik oder wer, was da was gerade in der Politik los ist, ihre Empfehlungen abgeben. Ist ja gerade der Witz an der.
Ja klar, STIKO ist nochmal ein anderes Problem so, aber Politik kommt natürlich noch mit dazu, gerade wenn's um solche Entscheidungen geht, es hing ja jetzt nicht alles nur an der STIKO. Teilweise hat sich die Politik ja auch über die STIKO schon hin äh hinweggesetzt.
Das stimmt, das stimmt, äh aber
natürlich ist es, sagen wir mal, zu einer Niedriginzidenzzeit. Also will will sagen, klar, am Ende ist die Politik natürlich auch äh für die STIKO und,
Arbeit verantwortlich und wie das dort fluppt, also die Endverantwortung liegt natürlich immer bei der Politik.
Aber hier äh sage ich mal, ist auf jeden Fall äh auch eine hohe Teilschuld oder ein Teil der Verzögerung ist tatsächlich auf die Arbeit der STIKO auch zurückzuführen, weil die hätten das einfach empfehlen können. Die Daten waren da
und dann wäre das auch losgegangen unabhängig davon, was die Politik macht. So ja insofern
ja ist es sozusagen indirektes also mehr indirektes Politikversagen äh aber klar.
Pretty Kette, äh wie du so richtig sagst, hätte sich auch darüber hinwegsetzen können, aber da war natürlich ein Nulldruck. Im August da.
Ja, na gut, also für mich war das natürlich jetzt überhaupt erst mal ähm äh in mit Israel erst mal dahingehend interessant zu sehen, wie,
wird's denn da konkret gehandhabt, ne,
sich ja überhaupt erst sehr kurzfristig da ein Zeitfenster geöffnet, das machen zu können, denn es gab die Ankündigung von Israel, nachdem sie eben mit ihrer Bußerei ihre Inzidenz, die ja sehr hoch war,
Ne, also auch höher als wir es äh derzeit in Deutschland haben.
Da sind sie halt mit der ganzen Boosterei wieder massiv dagegen vorgegangen. Dann ging die Inzidenz auch wieder schnell zurück und ist jetzt halt in einem sehr niedrigen Bereich.
Und ham dann ihren ähm Reiseband in zwei Schritten zurückgenommen. Also ich glaube im
im im Oktober noch gab's schon mal eine Lockerung für organisierte Reisegruppen, also wenn man quasi in irgendeiner Form in so einer Reisegruppe touristisch organisiert war
war ein Besuch schon wieder möglich und ab dem 1. November war dann eben auch das individuelle Reisen, also ohne Reisegruppe drumherum auch möglich und die Gelegenheit habe ich dann mal einfach wahrgenommen.
Was waren die Voraussetzungen?
Ja genau und die Voraussetzungen, die waren vielfältig. Also erst mal musstest du.
Also generell ist natürlich Einreisen in Israel ist sowieso immer so eine Sache, ne, also da musst du dann schon mal relativ klar immer dokumentieren, wo willst du hin, wo willst du übernachten,
et cetera. Aber es kam natürlich jetzt durch die Corona-Situation noch mal ein paar Sachen dazu. Dazu gehört erstmal, du musst nachweisen, dass du eine entsprechende Reisekrankenversicherung hast, die
auch Coronafälle abdeckt.
Die halt im Ausland gilt und brauchst dann ein entsprechendes Dokument äh auf Englisch. Hat sich zwar letzten Endes niemand angeschaut, aber ist auf jeden Fall eine offizielle Voraussetzung und man muss immer davon ausgehen, dass so was auch mal abgefragt wird.
Sehr viel wichtiger war dann aber, dass man einen aktuellen PCR-Test es in 72 Stunden maximal alt, also drei Tage.
Zum Zeitpunkt des Reiseantritts, also am Flughafen quasi.
Im letzten Check-In vorlegen muss. Also das wurde dann geguckt, dass man diesen äh negativen Test hat äh zu dem Zeitpunkt des,
Boardings. Also es ging dann irgendwie rein und da wo man eigentlich normalerweise nur noch Bodding Pass zeigt und seinen Ausweis musste man dann eben auch diesen PCR-Test und auch eine,
Registrierung,
vorweisen. Das ist jetzt auch nix, was Israel alleine macht. Das äh hatte ich neulich auch in Spanien, dass man also vorher online sagen muss, hallo, ich komme.
Hier ist mein Impfpass.
Den lädt man entsprechend hoch und dokumentiert, dass man geimpft ist. Das war natürlich eh die Voraussetzung, ganz klar, also nur mit Test alleine, das hätte jetzt nicht funktioniert, sondern man musste eben doppelt
geimpft sein, beziehungsweise eben auch dreifach, wenn das schon länger als sechs Monate her ist, also Booster wäre dann auch vorgeschrieben gewesen.
Genau und das kann man dann erst einen Tag vorher machen, dann lädt man seinen Impfpass hoch und kriegt dann auch relativ zügig eine Antwort mit einem entsprechenden Dokument, was alles auf hebräisch ist. Das muss man irgendwie ausdrucken oder sollte man zumindest ausdrucken.
Und man erhält aber auch schon,
einen sogenannten Green Parce und das ist quasi der in Israel gültige äh Nachweis, dass man ausreichend geimpft ist und sich in alle möglichen Lokalitäten begeben kann. Das wurde,
immer überprüft bei Veranstaltungen und äh in Hotels. Nicht unbedingt immer gescannt,
Das Übliche, ne, also auch da haben die Leute diesen evolutionären Schritt, dass die QR-Codes direkt mit dem Auge lesen können,
schon äh hinter sich gebracht. Also in der Hinsicht ist da auch nicht alles perfekt, aber man merkt ja schon oder sie hat, ich hatte zumindest den Eindruck, das, was so das Überprüfen an sich betrifft.
Also das überhaupt erst mal danach gefragt wird, das ist schon irgendwie mehr Bild-In als bei uns, auch wenn sich das dann jetzt auch langsam angleicht.
Okay also Test, PCR-Test, Anmeldung Nachweis der eigenen Impfung.
Und die äh Reisekrankenversicherung, die explizit Corona abdeckt.
Dadrüber nachdenken, war noch irgendwas? Nee, ich glaube, das war's dann im Wesentlichen. Dann Rennenflieger.
Klar und dann ging's dahin und äh dann ist man so dreieinhalb Stunden glaube ich unterwegs.
Wenn man dann ankommt, hat man halt so diese üblichen Flughafen plus Israel äh,
Prozeduren, also da wird man dann irgendwie X mal X mal wird der Pass angeguckt und gefragt, was man denn hier will und überhaupt so das Übliche.
Das war alles kein Problem und dann.
Kommt man dann quasi in diesem Benguillon-Flughafen äh an und ist dann an dem Punkt, wo man normalerweise eben,
das Land betritt.
Mhm.
Also das eigentliche Outlet, so du hast deinen Koffer zack bum passt es nochmal überprüft worden, alles supi, kommst rein,
Und dann bist du aber nicht gleich draußen. Sondern dann ist es halt so, dass sie dort eine riesige Halle freigeräumt haben, durch die du dann zwangsläufig durchmarschieren musst, an dem.
Ungefähr so 50 covid Probenentnahmeplätze sind, die auch,
soweit ich das einschätzen konnte weitgehend alle besetzt waren. Also da war.
Zwar jetzt kein Riesenandrang gerade, weil das hängt ja immer davon ab, wie die Flugzeuge gerade kommen.
Aber es war auf jeden Fall gut besetzt und man äh hat dann relativ schnell einen Platz gefunden, wo dann eben.
Nochmal ein äh ja eine Probe entnommen werden musste für einen weiteren verpflichtenden PCR-Test. Also der PCR-Test um,
einzureisen reicht halt nicht aus, sondern man braucht diesen zweiten Test
die muss man oder konnte man vorher bezahlen, dann ist er auch ein bisschen billiger, hätte man auch noch vor Ort machen können, also man konnte den vorher schon buchen und dann äh nachweisen, dass man schon bezahlt hat mit einem Barcode, das heißt die scannen kurz den Beleg, dass man das bezahlt hat, damit hinten auch
ganzen Daten schon äh hinterlegt und dann.
Da werden zwei Proben entnommen, das heißt Pooltest äh und halt Individualtest, wenn der Pool positiv ist. Ja, die beiden Proben entnehmen sie einem, zack, rein, Beutel, zack, Aufkleber drauf.
Mit QR-Codes und diesen ganzen üblichen Schnaß und dann kriegt man so ein Bändchen an den Arm geklemmt, dass man quasi Probe abgegeben hat.
Und dann darf man einreisen.
Und man muss da nicht sofort in Quarantäne. Das ist jetzt quasi das Privileg für Leute, die eben diesen Impfnachweis haben. Wenn man also rein darf, äh aber nicht geimpft ist, dann muss oder aus bestimmten Ländern kommt, die,
andere Anforderungen haben et cetera hätte das für mich auch bedeuten können, dass man noch mal zwei Wochen richtig in Quarantäne gehen muss.
Das war aber jetzt eben nicht mehr der Fall. Zumindest nicht für mich in dem Moment als jemand, der aus Deutschland einreist und.
Ähm ja und dann musste ich mich aber offiziell direkt äh zu dem Hotel begeben. Das war dann in einer anderen Stadt.
Ich durfte Züge, Taxis und so weiter alles benutzen um dahin zu kommen,
aber man war dann quasi angewiesen. Das wurde dann aber nicht weiter kontrolliert, dass man eben da bleibt, bis man dann entweder per SMS oder per E-Mail vom Testergebnis benachrichtigt wird, innerhalb von 24 Stunden.
Wie lange hat das gedauert bei dir?
Also wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, kam die Mail dann irgendwann nachts, als ich eh gepennt habe.
Am nächsten Morgen.
War's dann irgendwie durch. Also ich glaube, es kam sogar schon um zweiundzwanzig Uhr und ich habe den Test um vierzehn Uhr oder so abgegeben. Also es ging relativ zügig.
Nehme mal an, in meinem Fall war das dann einfach so, dass der ganze Pool negativ war.
Hätte es vielleicht noch ein bisschen länger dauern können. Bei anderen Leuten hat's ja ehnlich ähnlich funktioniert. Ja und dann hatte ich aber zu dem Zeitpunkt schon meinen Green Pass, der quasi schon ab dem,
Folgetag galt. Also ich brauchte nun auch kein neues Dokument. Ich bin mir jetzt nicht sicher, was passiert wäre, wäre mein Test positiv gewesen. Dann ähm.
Keine Ahnung. Ähm ist mir auch nicht so nochmal explizit klargemacht worden, aber ich gehe mal davon aus, dann hätten die sich schon gemeldet und äh.
Na und dich wahrscheinlich dann in irgendwo in Quarantä.
Dann hätte mich äh ich mich wahrscheinlich wirklich charantänisieren müssen und regelmäßig testen müssen und dann wäre es wahrscheinlich richtig kompliziert gewesen, aber.
War aber negativ, von daher alles gut und ich konnte die paar Tage da genießen und ja einfach mal wieder in so einem Land sein, wo niedrige Inzidenzen sind und was ja
sagen wir mal schon gewissen ja.
Wo jetzt in Bussen und Bahnen relativ stringent Masken getragen wurden nicht unbedingt jetzt in allen Läden immer aber ja wo so eine Mischung ist aus.
Situation hat sich äh verbessert, aber man ist trotzdem vorsichtig. Sagen wir's mal so.
Ja, wie waren die Inzidenzen so in welchem Bereich, weißt du da war's, was ist.
Ähm das müsste ich jetzt nochmal explizit nachschlagen, aber aus der äh Erinnerung heraus
dürfte das so im sehr niedrigen Bereich gewesen sein. Ich schaue mal ganz kurz. Das war also hier.
Da war es so richtig niedrig ähm auf einem Million. Also null Komma sieben ja so neunzehn.
Ja, ja.
Also auch nicht mega niedrig.
Also nicht so mega niedrig wie bei uns im Sommer, aber es ist ja da auch erstens Winter, gut zweiundzwanzig Grad.
Ähm uns fluktiert auch grad wieder so ein bisschen, aber halt jetzt nichts, was ähm alle Alarmglocken schrillen lässt, ne.
Ja. Was nehme ich daraus mit?
Man kann man kann sowas sehr professionell machen. Jetzt muss man natürlich sagen, dass Israel insofern auch ein paar Vorteile hat erstmal.
Das ist nun mal ein Land, was ohnehin schon relativ gut abgeriegelt ist so gegenüber seinen Nachbarländern. Also es ist nicht so, dass man jetzt so,
permanenten Grenzverkehr hätte, wie das halt in Deutschland ist. Ich meine, äh nach Deutschland sickert halt einfach am laufenden Meter.
Überall Leute über die Grenze ein. Klar, also das ist irgendwie kein Vergleich. Außerdem haben sie auch nur diesen einen einzigen internationalen Flughafen, über den halt alles rein und rauskommt und da dann die entsprechende Infrastruktur aufzubauen.
Geht, ne? Trotzdem stört mich einfach diese,
totale Abwesenheit von irgendwelchen Tests an an deutschen Flughäfen mit internationalem Verkehr, ja. Also ich bin mir nicht so ganz so sicher, wie es jetzt aus non-EU-Ländern ist, ob da noch mal anders vorgegangen wird, aber ich habe Vergleichbares jetzt so noch nicht gesehen.
Also ich meine, das ist das hatten wir auch vor ich meine schon als äh ähm,
so die äh als Delta äh kam. Mitglied bei jeder Variante hatten wir das ja, dass wir dann festgestellt haben,
okay, äh eigentlich können die Leute einreisen, ohne dass wirklich irgendwie was passiert und sind dann zwar
aufgefordert, äh selbst wenn sie dann positiv sind oder so äh oder sich sich dann in Heimquarantäne
äh zu begeben, ja. Äh Quarantänehotels oder so scheinen scheinen nicht so das deutsche Ding.
Zu sein an der Stelle und wo dann halt klar war, dass natürlich viele Leute dann erstmal äh ja nach der Einreise dann äh ja dann zumindest dann ihre hm,
Bewohner dann äh problemlos anstecken äh können oder so, wenn sie dann irgendwie Familie äh sind und ja also.
Es wäre auch äh äh ich meine wir hatten ja nun gerade jetzt ist es ja wieder ein bisschen anders, aber innerlich erste äh Welle
Alles war zu, Hotels waren zu, alle haben gelitten. Ja, also einfach die Hotels einfach auch als Quarantäneorte zu nutzen, hätte sich hier so dermaßen angeboten, wurde aber nicht gemacht.
Ne
In anderen Ländern also auch in San Francisco äh beziehungsweise in den Kalifornien war's äh sogar so, dass äh du als Familienmitglied, also es zu jeder Zeit sagen konntest, hier ähm so
Ich äh bin positiv oder wie auch immer, ich möchte mich in Quarantäne begeben, dann hast du einen
Ereignis, da ist so ein Hotelzimmer äh gestellt gekriegt. Ja, du konntest dich also dann sagen, auch deine Familie schützen und das wurde bezahlt. So, ja.
Aber gut äh so so.
Innovativ.
Wichtig, so wichtig war's dann jetzt doch nicht irgendwie,
Varianten äh Einschleppung äh zu verhindern, als dass man irgendwie leerstehende Hotels irgendwie finanziell stattdessen hat, den wahrscheinlich lieber Coronahilfen ausgezahlt, dafür, dass sie die Zimmer leer stehen lassen, so. Ja.
Ja also das habe ich auch nicht verstanden. Also es ist einfach wirklich.
Ja und ich meine das das das Grundproblem äh scheint zu sein, aber bevor wir jetzt zu tief äh so in dieses Rabbit äh äh Hole reinsteigen. Also,
prinzipielles Problem scheint zu sein, dass äh ja Deutschland einfach
nicht wirklich regiert wird oder regiert wurde, sondern verwaltet.
Definitiv, also das ist klar. Das ist klar.
Und ja.
Deswegen ja also Politik ja äh immer zu spät äh so und äh Verwaltung irgendwie immer zu schwerfällig und äh ja.
Na ja gut, aber äh vielleicht sollten wir dann jetzt mal langsam zu den Deutschlandzahlen kommen oder hattest du noch.
Denke ich auch, genau. Also da ist es ja, also mein Bericht war jetzt in dem Sinne abgeschlossen oder hast du noch irgendwelche Fragen?
Ja, nee, nee, nee, mir fiel nur auf, wie gesagt, ich bin jetzt äh das einzige Mal, dass ich gereist bin jetzt so in den letzten Wochen mal. Einmal in die Schweiz und da ist mir eben auch aufgefallen
mit den Kontrollen so halbgar war, also auf dem Hinweg, ja, was dann auch die entsprechenden Dokumente so aber wurde dann auch so eher salopp,
äh kontrolliert und nach der Einreise gab's auch keinen Test oder so und,
bei der Rückkehr nach Deutschland war einfach gar nichts und auch mit Leuten, die ich gesprochen hatte. Irgendwie so, ja eigentlich kann hier jeder einreisen, wie er will, ohne dass irgendwie da was kontrolliert,
oder so. Das war so das der der Tenor. Also ich habe jetzt nichts wahrgenommen äh so organisatorisch oder irgendwie äh
dass man bei der Einreise irgendwas äh machen oder sagen oder tun musste nach.
Aspekt vielleicht noch ähm Israel ist ja an sich jetzt kein besonders günstiges Land. Also man muss da schon äh für manche Dinge relativ viel Geld zahlen.
Der Einreise PCR-Test, ja, wohlgemerkt gepult, ähm hat mich beim Kauf vor,
Abflug, weiß nicht genau, wie der Preis danach gewesen wäre. Ich glaube, da gab's noch mal ein Discount. Äh dreiundzwanzig Euro gekostet.
Also man kann sowas auch für so einen Preis äh organisieren und äh so was auch zwingend vorzuschreiben, ist einfach auch mal nicht so doof, weißt du? Also Frankfurt.
Mhm und äh vielleicht noch was, wenn gerade einfällt, diese Horrormeldung äh aus äh äh Holland ähm,
Hatten, wo ähm so in zwei Fliegern von irgendwie sechshundert Passagieren 60 positiv waren
bei der Ankunft, so wo ich mir dann auch gesagt habe, Holladie, Waldfee, äh wenn irgendwie also äh ich hätte keine Lust jetzt mit einem Flieger unterwegs zu sein, wo zehn Prozent der Passagiere gerade,
Corona infiziert sind so, also nachdem ich das gehört habe, äh äh genau, der kam ja aus Südafrika.
Ein paar Stunden äh äh alle schön im Flieger sitzen lassen, weil sie erstmal nicht wissen, was sie machen sollten und dann wurden auch wieder Masken nicht getragen, also unter Umständen haben sie das in dem Moment auch alles erst so richtig provoziert.
Naja gut, so also so schnell wird's wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht gehen, also die haben wahrscheinlich dann im Nachhinein äh kam sicherlich noch einiges nach, weil sie wohl die Leute dann, weil irgendwie nicht nicht nicht genug Platz war, haben sie dann stundenlang in einen Raum eingepfercht. Äh so das.
Das war nicht im Flugzeug.
Das war im Flughafen äh
so die haben die dann im im Flughafen irgendwie in einen Raum alle gepackt und wo dann die Hälfte keine richtigen Masken getragen hat oder die nicht über die Nase.
Ist jetzt auch alles äh erst seit zwei Jahren mit diesem ganzen Corona kann man jetzt nie erwarten, dass man an so einem Flughafen vielleicht für so einen Fall schon mal irgendwas vorgesorgt hätte.
Ja, ja, ja.
Gottchen, ja genau, also der Flug zurück ist auch nochmal interessant, also ich muss mich natürlich rückzug nicht testen, ich musste natürlich für meinen Flug nach Deutschland auch nicht mehr machen als ähm.
Muss ich denn machen? Ich muss genau, ich musste auch noch mal meinen Impfpass hochladen, also impfen war schon angesagt. Ich weiß jetzt auch wieder nicht, was gewesen wäre, wenn nicht ehrlich zu sein. Aber,
ein bisschen erschreckend fand ist, dass dann.
Auf dem Rückflug gefühlt na ja, ich würde mal sagen, so 60, 70 Prozent der,
Fluggäste und zum meinem zu meiner Erschütterung auch nochmal so 40 Prozent des Flugpersonals nur mit diesen Mund-Nase-Schutz,
Masken ausgerüstet waren. Ich habe dann extra noch mal, es war Lufthansa, habe da extra nochmal in die Lufthansa,
Bedingungen reingeschaut zu ihren aktuellen Corona, was sie so sagen, was man eigentlich alles so berücksichtigen sollte und da stand dann halt drin, ja nee äh nur FFP2-Maske ist,
erlaubt. Wo ich halt sagen muss.
Ihr seid doch sonst immer so scharf drauf noch äh an Bord Geld zu machen. Warum habt ihr nicht einfach FFP2-Masken für 5 Euro im Verkauf?
Mhm.
Ja oder für zwanzig Euro und erzählt jedem irgendwie aufm Platz so ja sorry, aber hier Mund-Nasen-Schutz geht nicht, aber wir haben hier rein zufällig,
günstige FFP2-Maske. Die kannst du jetzt kaufen oder du kannst dich jetzt wieder äh zurückbegeben und nicht mitfliegen. Youtube.
Mhm. Ja.
Ähm das ist das eine und das andere ist, warum bitte halt das Personal keine FFP2-Maske an.
Na ja gut äh muss sagen aus äh ähm sagen der der
Also es könnte sogar sein, dass bei dem Mund-Nasen-Schutz der Fremdschutz äh äh höher ist oder zumindest genauso gut ist
äh wie beinahe äh FFP2-Maske nur der Eigenschutz äh ist halt praktisch nicht gegeben. Na ja auch das Thema, was äh FFP,
O2-Masken nur zum Einatmen zertifiziert sind und äh die OP-Masken nur zum Ausatmen, ja, aber es gibt keine Maskensorte, die irgendwie auf
ein- und ausatmen zertifiziert, also wo geprüft wird, ähm was die zurückhält beim ein oder beim Ausatmen und
bei der äh insofern ja ist es äh würde ich sagen ist es eher schlecht äh für das sowohl für das Personal, dass da,
arbeitet äh dass sie nur
den Mund-Nasen-Schutz tragen, aber dadurch würden jetzt vermutlich nicht mehr Keime in die Kabine getragen. Äh also sondern.
Ist halt, dass Dilever mit den mit den Masken, wie gesagt, es gibt
nur in also schon eigentlich wäre die Combo das Beste so sagen OP-Maske über FFP2 dann hast du beide Richtungen irgendwie zertifiziert,
aber ja.
Hin äh Zertifizierung her. Meine Erfahrung ist einfach die, es ist jetzt quasi so aus der Beobachtung der Leute. Wer mit so einer OP-Maske unterwegs ist,
im Alltag. Tendiert auch dazu generell die sehr viel nachlässiger zu tragen als Leute, die,
FFP2 unterwegs sind. Und das hat sich da auch in diesem Flugzeug deutlich gezeigt. Die sind dann auch nicht so richtig,
angebracht und dann hast du so links und rechts noch so offene äh Kanäle und die werden auch viel äh schneller äh äh sinken die so quasi unter den Nasenpimmelhorizont.
Genau und ich gucke die Nase raus. Das wäre ja immer.
Es ist da einfach Standard und das ist bei FFP2 eher die Ausnahme.
Wobei das krasseste war so ein Bild, was ich jetzt gesehen habe, äh das Absurdeste. Ich meine nicht, ob du,
darauf gestoßen bist, aber aus einer amerikanischen Schule beim Querflöte spielen, wo sie dann quasi damit die Kinder äh hatten die Kinder Masken auf, aber
die waren ausgeschnitten so also Mund und Nase waren quasi ausgeschnitten, damit sie Querflöte spielen können, aber
weil halt sozusagen die Regularien irgendwie Masken vorschrieben, haben dann irgendwelche Schwachmaten dann auf die Idee gekommen, okay so haben die Kinder jetzt eine Maske auf, aber äh ja äh.
Also das das war so ein bisschen so der wirklich der Gipfel der der Idiotie muss man äh sagen so also.
Den haben wir noch nicht erreicht, glaube ich, den Gipfel der Idiotie.
Gut dann äh lass uns mal schauen, wie denn sich so das ganze Infektionsgeschehen.
In Deutschland entwickelt hat. Danach schauen wir auch noch mal auf den Fortschritt der Impfkampagne. Da tut sich ja mittlerweile wieder was, das sich mal lohnt sich die Zahlen mal genauer anzuschauen.
Ja, ja. Ja, Inzidenzen, also jetzt nach äh, wie gesagt, Veröffentlichungs-
Datum so deutschlandweit vierhundertzweiundachtzig ähm gerade und.
Könnte sein, dass wir einen Gipfel erreicht haben, also zumindest jetzt so seit ein paar Tagen, seit einer
Woche ungefähr stagnieren die Zahlen mehr oder weniger mit einem leichten Knick äh nach unten, also die die Inzidenzen, wobei
kommen wir noch drauf, dass nicht in allen Bundesländern der Fall ist und auch nicht in allen Altersgruppen. Ähm
Ja, aber äh bedauerlicherweise steigt halt die äh Zahl der Toten weiter. Wir sind jetzt bei 2092 Todesfällen
in den letzten sieben Tagen und wie gesagt, der R-Wert, also sieben Tage äh,
ähm äh liegt jetzt bei null Komma neun neun neun also bei eins äh äh praktisch.
Glaubst du denn diesen Zahlen?
Ähm ja.
Ich höre jetzt nur davon, dass dass die ganzen
Testkapazitäten auch wirklich an den Rand kommen und dass die ganzen Testzentren gar nicht mehr in der Lage sind rechtzeitig äh alles abzuarbeiten, dass die einfach überlaufen und äh die Tests verschieben.
Dann nehmen wir, ziehen wir das mal mit den Tests vor. Ähm
Also zumindest laut RKI äh laut deren Testzahlen äh
ist die Testkapazität deutlich höher, also liegt wohl deutschlandwei,
irgendwie bei zwei zwischen zweieinhalb und 2,7 Millionen und gemacht wurden 1,9 Millionen Tests. Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass wir da jetzt irgendwie schon voll in der Sättigung äh äh wären?
Gut, aber das ist ja dann deutschlandweit gemittelt, sondern du hast ja in einzelnen Ländern, also in Thüringen und Sachsen, da äh kommen sie nicht hinterher.
Ja, aber ich habe mir deswegen auch angesehen, wie sich so die äh Meldeverzögerung am Meer fahren wir ja auch immer.
Über die Meldeverzögerung oder Publikationsverzögerung und äh die,
sieht jetzt ähm ja äh gut, die ist
angestiegen, aber es gibt nirgendwo der Median ist entweder irgendwie null oder ein Tage äh ja und äh
das sieht jetzt nicht so aus, außer jetzt in Sachsen, äh so in Sachsen hat den den den höchsten Mittelwert, somit fünf Komma neun
Tagen, aber ähm das liegt auch daran, dass irgendwie immer noch plötzlich Meldungen jetzt eintreffen. Also die Älteste, die in den letzten
die die die da eingetroffen ist in Sachsen ist jetzt 408 Tage alt. So das treibt natürlich den,
408 Tage aus ja sagen äh da ist hat also
Ja äh oder also äh es ist nicht nur ein Einzelfall, sondern in anderen Bundesländern auch so hundertdreizehn, dreihundertvierundzwanzig, zweihunderteinundfünfzig aber die Ältesten irgendwie fünfhundertsechsundfünfzig Tage
äh her. Weil sie irgendwelche Korrekturen in der in der Datenbasis oder irgendwelche Altfälle äh die da kommen, aber es.
Gut, aber das das zieht das sagt ja dann über nichts mehr über das aktuelle Verzögerungsgeschehen aus.
Nee äh das ist äh da ist der Median, äh wie gesagt also die die sozusagen ähm so wo ungefähr die Hälfte der Meldungen
Ähm,
älter und die Hälfte der Meldungen äh äh neuer ist äh und der ist wie gesagt null oder eins, also mit anderen Worten ich habe jetzt nicht gesehen, dass da die Meldeverzöger oder die Publikationsverzögerung jetzt dramatisch gewachsen wäre, was
normalerweise der also was der Fall wäre, wenn keine Ahnung die Leute jetzt also wenn die Tests äh auf Halde.
Äh liegen und allerdings das RKI hat dann auch äh ja hatte so eine Statistik über Proben-Rückstau.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ob die aufgehört haben, die zu führen oder ob es keinen mehr gibt, aber da sind für die letzten wenn ich 20 Wochen äh Probenrückstau null
eingetragen. So insofern, aber wie gesagt, es also ich habe jetzt keine Hinweise darauf gefunden, äh dass wir mit den Tests äh jetzt wirklich dramatisch äh in äh in eine Sättigung
äh reinlaufen. Ähm allerdings äh natürlich wenn man jetzt einen Blick auf die positiven,
Quote werfen und also sowohl
Die Anzahl der Tests als auch die Anzahl der positiven Tests als auch die positiv Quote sind auf einem absoluten Rekordniveau.
Und ähm ja in in Zahlen ähm
sieht es so aus. Ich habe ja eins Komma neun fünf Millionen Tests in der siebenundvierzigsten Kalenderwoche, also bis zum Ende der Woche bis zum achtundzwanzigsten Elften.
Ist das immer 45.919 davon waren positiv, also vierhunderttausend
neue Infektionen in den letzten
sieben Tagen mit einem Anstieg auch von um 80 Prozent gegenüber der Vorwoche. Also wir hatten es immer so wöchentliche Anstiege
so in der Gegend von 70 bis 80 Prozent äh mehr und die positiven Quote jetzt ja bei,
einundzwanzig Kommaeins neun Prozent. So positiv war's noch nie.
Und.
Halt äh positiv hier negativ heißt eigentlich.
Genau, so Deutschland noch nie so positiv, ja. Ähm nee, nee und äh was das natürlich, also eine Konsequenz
davon ist
natürlich, dass wir wahrscheinlich eine deutlich höhere Dunkelziffer haben und so richtig abschätzen kann man das jetzt nur ganz schwer, weil auf der anderen früher war es möglich, das über die Zahl der Toten
zu kalibrieren äh so ein bisschen aber es geht halt jetzt wegen Impfungen, man hat sich das halt alles
so ein bisschen verschoben. Ähm aber was man sagen kann ist, dass äh sieht die
sicherlich nicht runtergegangen ist und dass man eigentlich die Inzidenzwerte mindestens mal drei, vielleicht mal fünf sogar nehmen müsste, um auf die tatsächliche Zahl der der Infektionen
zu kommen. Also andern Worten.
Ja bei bei den äh Inzidenzen äh so bei einer Tausender-Inzidenzen so ein. Also man kann sagen, dass jetzt je nach,
Bundesland so zwischen äh nicht zwei und zwei bis 5 Prozent der Bevölkerung, der Zeit gerade infiziert sind. Die meisten davon, ohne es zum Wissen oder zum merken wahrscheinlich.
Ich gucke grad mal, weil mich das jetzt gerade interessiert. Also Israel haben wir ja vorhin drüber gesprochen. Ich vergleiche das jetzt einfach mal. Hatte ja im September die höchsten Infektionszahlen.
Also da ging das noch sehr viel höher als wir es jetzt in Deutschland hatten.
Ähm das Maximum lag knapp bei tausend oder kurz dadrunter neunhunderter Inzidenz.
Hast du die positiven Quote auch dazu irgendwo?
Genau, darauf wollte ich nämlich jetzt hinaus und zu dem Zeitpunkt hatten sie eine positiven Quote von ungefähr sechs oder sieben Prozent.
Zu einem Zeitpunkt als sie eine sehr viel höhere Inzidenz hatten.
Waren sie noch in bei der Positiv-Quote noch in einem Bereich.
Ja so um also bisschen höher als fünf Prozent, aber noch mal zur Erinnerung fünf Prozent. Das ist so in etwa das, wovon man ausgeht, wenn man eine fünfprozentige positiven Quote.
Dann hat man das Geschehen im Blick. Dann weiß man, was Phase ist, so. Wir,
haben jetzt eine Inzidenz von 500, also ungefähr so knapp,
die Hälfte von dem was Israel zum aller allerhöchsten Peak hatte aber wir haben halt eine positiven Quote die äh locker viermal so hoch ist.
Das heißt.
Das will wahrscheinlich nicht ansatzweise gerade das Geschehen einfangen und das obwohl wir so viele Tests haben wie noch nie zuvor mit irgendwie fast zwei Millionen.
Na ja, ja, aber es äh ja aber es scheint nicht an der Testkapazität zu liegen, sondern äh ja entweder vielleicht an der.
Am Unwillen der Leute sich zu testen oder an sehr sehr vielen milden Verläufen, ja, die wir die wir haben. Das.
Kann halt auch eine Ursache sein.
Dass äh ja viele Leute es einfach nicht merken oder sagen, ja jetzt irgendwie einen leichten Schnupfen oder irgendwie bisschen Kratzen im Hals.
Gut, aber das ist die Frage, was was war da in Israel anders, dass sie das ähm dass sie sozusagen eine niedrige positive Quote hatte.
Weil ist ja nicht so, dass jetzt Israel andere also bessere Voraussetzungen hätte. Tatsächlich ist ja dort, dass die Bevölkerung sehr viel jünger.
Ja, was also jetzt dafür sprechen würde, dass wir dass sie da irgendwie jetzt besonders.
Angenehme äh Verläufe hätten oder so, ganz im Gegenteil, äh ist eher davon auszugehen, dass da die Verläufe nochmal milder sind.
Also habe ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt keine Erklärung äh für vielleicht ist es dort ein.
Einfacher äh einen einen PCR-Test zu kriegen, wobei das hier mittlerweile auch so
ist, ist glaube ich auch kein Problem. Ich glaube, du hast, glaube ich, sogar, wenn ich das richtig sehe, ich vertue mich nicht, aber ich meine so auf Anspruch auf einen PCR-Test pro Woche oder so, den du jetzt machen lassen kannst bei den Testzentren äh.
PCR-Test.
Ja. Mhm. Und einen mhm und einen kostenlosen Schnelltest pro Tag. Das ist war glaube ich die Quotierung irgendwie.
Das fällt mir jetzt gerade neu, dass man das darf. Nur ich dachte nur mit so rot mit mit irgendwie Hinweis und rote Corona-Warn-App und so weiter.
Ja, also äh ich habe das, ich hatte das jetzt auch nicht gecheckt, aber das war eben als ich äh selber mal zu einer so einer 2G-Plus-Veranstaltung bin und so ein Schnelltest äh gemacht hatte. Äh
hatte ich nur äh gesehen, dass man dort auch äh in den Testzentrum hier im an einer Kulturbrauerei
so das war jetzt das nächste Test.
Ein Schnelltest oder ein PCR-Test.
Die machen alles. Äh da kannst du sowohl kostenlosen Schnelltest äh machen äh als auch irgendwie einen Antigentest äh machen lassen als auch äh einen PCR-Test. So.
Und äh müssen wir nochmal äh äh sollten wir vielleicht nochmal checken, äh wie das wie das genau aussieht, aber ich meine ähm.
Äh
Gut, also auf jeden Fall ich fasse mal zusammen. Äh sieht nicht so geil aus.
Ist definitiv die höchste Infektionssituation, die wir äh hatten. Wir haben sie sehr viel früher als im letzten Jahr und wir haben sie, obwohl eben zwei Drittel Deutschlands geimpft.
Doppelt geimpft sind,
Ja, aber es reicht halt nicht aus, weil die allermeisten Leute von denen, die jetzt hier infiziert sind, sind vermutlich ungeimpft. Also ich sage jetzt mal vermutlich, weil da steckt jetzt in den Zahlen so nicht drin. Eine andere Information, die wir auch nicht haben.
Und von der ich auch denke mal gucken wie du das siehst, dass wir die auch nie haben werden ähm so wie das läuft, weil.
Wir können den Zahlen nicht ansehen, ob Leute, die jetzt positiv getestet sind.
Schon also erstmal, ob sie schon geimpft waren. Es geben die Zahlen nicht her.
Es gibt es teilweise in den Ländern, aber ähm wir wissen auch nicht,
ob die Leute, die jetzt positiv getestet sind, schon mal positiv getestet wurden,
Auch das ist so eine Information, die einfach nicht vorliegt. Und wo ich wieder sagen würde, das ist so eine Information, die hätte man eigentlich ganz gerne auch. So.
Und ich habe jetzt gerade nochmal nachgeguckt, ich habe mich vertan äh so der Labortest ist nicht äh gibt auch nicht das Anrecht darauf kostet neunundsiebzig Euro neunzig äh dort.
So und dann siehst du halt auch, warum zu wenig geti.
Ja OK ja.
Wie gesagt, so ein Pooltest in Israel, 23 Euro, ganz andere Nummer.
Und äh ja beziehungsweise wäre wahrscheinlich tatsächlich ein no Brainer äh zu sagen, okay eigentlich hat auch äh jeder Anspruch äh auf äh ich sage mal einen einen äh,
einen kostenlosen PCR-Test so. Was soll denn das eigentlich? Ich meine, äh ja.
Du meldest dich sicher jemand voll Gedanken drüber machen müssen ähm ja.
Er hätte hätte halt irgendwie ja äh Nachdenken erfordert und äh ja.
Handlungsbereitschaft auch. Oh ja, das geht ja gar nicht.
Und Geld gekostet natürlich wieder, dann äh ja. So. Lässt man lieber die Zahlen hochgehen und.
Genau. Vielleicht noch mal ähm zu den Auswirkungen, wo wir jetzt schon bei den Zahlen sind, wollte ich auch noch mal eine andere Zahl äh äh holen, beziehungsweise ich kann's in Zahlen gar nicht so richtig ausdrücken, aber,
Was wir ja auch von Anfang an ähm schon erhalten haben, sind diese Mobilitätstrends.
Ähm zur Erinnerung, das sind Daten, die vor allem von Apple und Google bereitgestellt werden und die auf,
Basis äh einer.
Anonym Auswertungen von Smartphone-Bewährungsprofilen äh erstellt werden. Es gibt solche Bewegungs-Mobilitätsdaten auch.
Für Deutschland, also zumindest sollte meiner Auffassung nach die Bundesregierung solche Informationen haben als Auswertung auch das Mobilfunkgeschehens von den.
Mobilfunkbetreiber. Hier sind's halt die Mobilitätstrends, die Apple und Google aus ihren Smartphones abziehen.
Gleich wieder alle schreien, mit oh mein Gott, wir werden überwacht.
Abgesehen davon, dass das schon teilweise so so ist, aber nicht in diesem Fall zwangsläufig, sondern das ist ja in der Regel das Ergebnis einer.
Anonymen Auswertungen dieser Daten auf der Basis der Technik der Differential Privacy. Was ist das? Differenzielle,
Privatsphäre kann man digital dadurch herstellen, dass quasi die Telefone schon sagen, so hallo, ich bin.
Oder ich bewege mich so und so, ja, aber sie lügen dabei auch äh zu einem definierten Maß. Sodass man quasi.
Einer Information,
als solcher gar nicht glauben kann, also jedes jede Information, die ein Telefon liefert, kann falsch sein, aber sie ist quasi im Mittel über alle Daten, die man einsammelt ähm
hat sie ein ein definierten Fallschwert, sodass man die Wahrheit da trotzdem rauslesen kann. Man kann nur der einzelnen Informationen nicht glauben.
Und wir hatten halt ähm zu Beginn der Pandemie im Januar.
So quasi so eine Basislevel.
Die null Prozent und als dann im März der erste Lockdown und der erste Schock kam, ging das so auf Minus,
70 Prozent runter. Wobei jetzt diese Zahl auch so ein Mittel ist aus Bewegung im ÖPNV, Bewegung ähm Fahren mit ähm,
Verkehrsfahrzeugen vermutlich primär Autos und dem Gehen. Das Gehen liegt immer so ein bisschen im Mittel, also da nehme ich mal das.
So das heißt es ging dann auf minus siebzig Prozent runter und dann dauerte es so bis zum Juli bis man wieder so auf so einem Null-Prozent-Level war. Dann hielt sich das den ganzen Sommer, also wohlgemerkt wir sind jetzt zwanzig zwanzig, ne?
Im Oktober zweite Welle in Deutschland ging's dann langsamer bergab. Ja dann wir erinnern uns, wir haben.
Gebraucht. Genau, Lockdown light. Der hat sich dann erst im Januar quasi zu Weihnachten wieder bei diesen Minus 60 bis 70 Prozent eingefunden und es dauerte dann wieder bis zum.
Juni.
Äh bis ich das normalisiert hat. Also jetzt Juni zwanzig einundzwanzig. Und dann war ja irgendwie Freedom angesagt und äh überhaupt und wir sind ja alle geimpft und äh die Aktivität ging ja also jetzt im Oktober,
weit über diese null Prozent hinaus. Also da hatten wir dann eher so 60 bis zu 100 Prozent mehr Aktivität noch bis in den
Oktober hinein.
Und jetzt erst seit Ende Oktober bis äh eben jetzt Ende November sieht man, dass diese Aktivität wieder zurückgeht und jetzt geht sie so ungefähr wieder auf null Prozent.
Mit anderen Worten,
Wir haben äh was die Mobilität der Bevölkerung betrifft, zwar einen spürbaren Rückgang, ja, aber der teilweise auch ein,
Rückgang oh also ein saisonaler Rückgang sein kann. Leider.
Gibt's diese Trends nicht für 2019? Das wäre mal ganz interessant, das damit zu vergleichen. Von daher fehlt mir jetzt dieser Vergleich. Trotz alledem kann man sagen, so ein Lockdown-Mobilitätseffekt lässt sich derzeit einfach noch nicht feststellen.
Oder zumindest sind wir auf einem ich sage mal Niveau auf einem äh äh mittleren Pandemieniveau oder äh so zurück oder auf sagen Niveau vom letzten Sommer oder äh auf Sommerniveau.
Man das so ausdrücken.
Ja oder einen, es gibt gar keine Pandemieniveau.
Mhm, ja gut, das ist ja jetzt nicht äh aber ja äh okay, mhm.
Ähm genau. Was auch noch sehr beunruhigend äh ist, ist generell, wie sich halt so die äh Belastung der oder die Auslastung der Intensivstationen entwickelt.
Ich habe da jetzt nicht so tief reingetaucht. Ich habe hier nur eine äh Übersicht ähm mal mir.
Twitter gegriffen, wo das mal nach Bundesländern aufgeschlüsselt ist, weil da zeigt sich dann halt doch schon ein extremes äh Bild in manchen Bundesländern wenig überraschend,
Baden-Württemberg,
Bayern, Thüringen und Sachsen, aber auch schon Mecklenburg-Vorpommern und ich glaube auch.
Sachsen-Anhalt, ja Sachsen-Anhalt nicht ganz so krass,
Aber die äh erst genannten auf jeden Fall dort ist die Auslastung der Intensivstation schon auf dem Niveau, wie wir's in der zweiten, respektive dritten Welle gehabt haben.
Auch alles schon ein bisschen auf Kante genäht waren und ja das ist halt so das andere Problem, ne. Da hat's ja die Sterbezahlen auch schon erwähnt. Die sind natürlich jetzt hoch und äh egal, was jetzt gerade,
stagniert oder so, also auch stagnierende Zahlen helfen uns an der Stelle auch überhaupt nicht weiter. Wir können davon ausgehen, dass so auch in den nächsten zwei Wochen.
Pro Tag mal locker vier-, fünfhundert Leute sterben werden an äh Covid-19. Und das heißt auch, dass wir gute Chancen haben.
Weiß nicht, wie ob du das mal ausgerechnet hast, aber das war ja auch so eine Ansage vom Drosten.
Wenn wir also das Niveau halten, dass wir mal locker die 100.000 Tote, die wir jetzt gerade gefeiert haben, äh sehr bald dann auch wieder noch oben drauf gelegt bekommen.
Also wir sind wir sind jetzt, ich meine was immer so ein bisschen anschaulicher äh äh ist, ist äh wenn man das
mal hochrechnet quasi das was so pro Woche jetzt
äh im Moment an Todesfällen äh da ist. Ähm wie viel das denn pro Jahr ausmachen würde, wenn das so weitergehen äh würde und
wir sind glaube ich, wenn ich das so im Kopf müsste, sind wir gerade auf einem zweihunderttausend pro Jahr Level, ja. Ähm
und äh aber steigend. Also da ist jetzt noch noch nix äh zu erkennen äh und wenn das jetzt aber wirklich die die Wende ist
gerade oder wenn wir jetzt schon auf dem äh tatsächlich auf dem Peak sein
sollten so, dann werden wir, glaube ich, jetzt nicht auf die hunderttausend kommen, hoffentlich, äh wenn das runtergeht, aber natürlich auch äh signifikant. Äh so, ich hab's jetzt ähm nicht genau ähm.
Kalkuliert. Mal gucken, aber äh ja. Sind auf jeden Fall einige zehntausend. Kann man äh sagen, die jetzt ja,
vermeidbar gewesen wären oder ein Großteil davon wahrscheinlich vermeidbar gewesen wäre und wer grad schon dabei,
sind in den Alters äh äh Gruppen da hatten wir.
Äh sind von den Zahlen so ein bisschen abgeschweift, aber ähm da ist es so, dass die.
Über 60-jährigen und die äh über 80-jährigen äh haben jetzt Inzidenzen deutschlandweit so von 270 respektive 240 in der Gegend und die gehen jetzt auch wieder wohl,
zurück in den Altersgruppen und etwas stärker zurück. Also der Knick ist dort etwas ausgeprägter äh als in den in den anderen Altersgruppen, wo es
eher horizontal äh geht. Aber wir haben halt äh so eine so eine lustige Clusterung,
nämlich die ganz Alten sagen bei rund 250, die Alters die mittleren Altersgruppen
bei um die 500, also Verdopplung und die Fünf- bis 4zehnjährigen bei tausend, also wieder eine Verdoppelung und
Die ganz Kleinen, die Null- bis Vierjährigen tummeln sich erstaunlicherweise von der Höhe her liefen die parallel mit den alten. So, was.
Ungewöhnliches. Das hatten wir so auch noch nicht, weil die sind ja ungeimpft. Aber irgendwas ist da halt komisch nur, äh ist,
bei den Null- bis Fünfjährigen aktuell steigt es jetzt noch weiter. Laut äh meinem Grafen, also das ist die einzige Altersgruppe, die jetzt keine Trendumkehr hat äh äh,
äh die noch nicht auf dem Peak ist. Aber normalerweise ja
liefen die immer so eher in der ja doch in der Mitte äh äh oder deutlich über den alten, aber haben sich da jetzt irgendwie mit den,
sagen mit in die Altersgruppe der die ganz Jungen und die ganz Alten sind jetzt letzten Monat fast komplett parallel gelaufen von der Inzidenz her.
Ja. Etwas seltsam. Und wenn wir jetzt noch mal in die Bundesländer reingucken.
Dann äh ergeben sich halt auch gewaltige Unterschiede.
So ähm Bremen und Schleswig-Holstein äh sagen, dass das Schlusslicht im Sinne von,
da passiert nicht hier so Schleswig-Holstein ist irgendwie ein Phänomen. Ich weiß nicht warum die da so ob die da irgendwie covid resistenter sind oder vorsichtiger oder.
Über irgendwie äh der äh äh der der Witz
äh so als es als es darum äh ging äh sagen diese Zwei-Meter-Regel einzuführen, meint jemand also so nahe gehe ich sowieso nicht an Leute ran, ja. Also wie wir müssen uns jetzt auf zwei Meter aneinander annähern.
So das war dann so ein bisschen der Witz, dass die Leute dort sowieso nicht sowieso Abstand halten.
Aber äh keine Ahnung, wie war das äh jetzt ist, aber äh Fakt ist, dass äh so ja in Schleswig-Holstein einfach mal äh das covid-resistenteste Land zu sein scheint.
Und äh ja Bremen hat sich da auch ganz gut aus Niedersachsen auch irgendwie Hamburg auch irgendwie.
Ganz gut aus. Wir reden hier immer noch von Inzidenzen, von äh Schleswig-Holstein 15 und Bremen und Hamburg und so weiter alles im zweihunderter Bereich.
Ja
Aber äh gut, also insofern gut, es ist ein bisschen übertrieben, aber wir müssten die Zahlen wahrscheinlich so wie um sie vergleichen zu können, ungefähr halbieren.
So mit den vorherigen.
Wäre ja.
Äh so ja.
Insofern äh kann man eher sagen, so im Vergleich zu früheren Wellen 70 bis 100 äh liegen die. Ja, das ist nicht gut so.
Aber äh ja
es ist auf jeden Fall, wenn wir mal an die Spitze gucken Sachsen mit tausendvierhundertzweiundneunzig ja nach
alles äh äh nach Publikationsdatum und Thüringen mit tausendsiebzig Sachsen-Anhalt mit achthundertdreiundvierzig, Brandenburg mit äh äh siebenhundertneununddreißig okay und äh ja Bayern fünfhundertneunundachtzig,
und so die liegen alle noch noch etwas über im Schnitt. Baden-Württemberg auch und Mecklenburg-Vorpommern auch und dann äh ja der Rest der Länder, die jetzt nicht genannt wurden, liegen halt unter dem Durchschnitt.
Irgendwo ja zwischen ich sage 250 und,
äh 3hundert65, was was jetzt die Berliner Inzidenz gerade äh ist.
Einzige Land von denen, wo's richtig schlimm ist, wo man wirklich so einen so einen Abwärtstrend richtig äh sieht an den Grafiken, ist Bayern. Alles andere
bremst sich ein bisschen aus, wenn überhaupt so, weil Thüringen geht's nach wie vor äh wild zur Sache und wird sich sicherlich noch verschlechtern. In der nächsten Woche, so wie das aussieht, also.
Das heißt, die Trendwende, wenn man sich das genauer anguckt, so
ist vor allem auf Bayern und ja ein bisschen auf Sachsen zurückzuführen äh denke ich mal. In allen anderen Ländern
ja gut stagniert's entweder oder steigt also in Berlin
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern. Wir ziehen die Inzidenzen
äh äh ganz schön an. Berlin macht auch einen Knick nach unten und Thüringen scheint der Anstieg auch noch ungebrochen zu sein und Sachsen-Anhalt scheint auch wieder nochmal anzusetzen. Also mit anderen Worten
Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass dass es eine deutschlandweite Trendwende gibt, sondern es gibt halt eine Trendwende in einigen Ländern und in anderen Ländern gibt es noch keine Trendwende und
dass es jetzt äh kann man sagen, ist so ein bisschen die Situation. Ja. Und.
Ansonsten ja vielleicht noch mal was wir lange nicht mehr gemacht haben, so einen Blick mal in die Kreise so in die Top dreißig meiner Risikoliste.
Und da haben wir dann jetzt so
auch äh sich Mittelsachsen, also das heißt vor allem Sachsen und äh Thüringen ähm somit richtig äh.
Hohen äh Inzidenzen so äh ja Landkreis Mittelsachsen 2158 ist jetzt grade ähm äh auf auf Platz eins der Risikoliste, weil hohe Inzidenz
und 90 Prozent mehr Infektionen in der letzten Woche beziehungsweise einen R-Wert von 1,44äh dort dann ist Schmalkalden-Meiningen, Thüringen auf Platz zwei
auch mit ja mit zwar nur mit 1.671 Inzidenz
aber mit noch einem höheren Ehrwert von eins Komma vier sieben
Und äh ja sächsische Schweiz Ostergebirge auch ein bekannter Kandidat jetzt mal Platz 6 nur auf der Risikoli.
Osterzgebirge, nicht Ostergebirge.
Habe.
Das hatten wir schon mal.
Ja
Bevor jetzt wieder die Kommenta.
Äh äh sorry ja äh ich bin da oft genug durchgefahren, als dass ich das eigentlich äh wissen müsste, aber äh ja äh.
Ist eigentlich auch ganz schön da, aber ist halt ähm.
Ja, lass mir mein Ostergebirge äh ja okay, Osterzgebirge. Ähm ja mit 2200achter Inzidenz ähm,
So äh und äh ja, also es sieht sieht alles nicht nicht gut aus, wenn man dann überlegt.
Dass dann wahrscheinlich noch eine Dunkelziffer äh da ist, ist es so, dass dort jetzt in den Landkreisen so jeder Zehnte grade, der da rumläuft, potenziell infiziert ist. Ja, einer von zehn.
So das ist schon heftig.
Das ist in der Tat heftig.
Ähm in dem Zusammenhang, also wenn man schon mal sich die Inzidenzen anschaut, ist es glaube ich auch mal ganz interessant, sich anzuschauen, so wie ist es denn insgesamt äh gelaufen?
In den einzelnen Landkreisen und das war jetzt nicht nach Inzidenzen, sondern eben nach nach Todesfällen. Also wenn man sich jetzt wirklich mal anschaut, wie viele Leute sind denn insgesamt in diesen Landkreisen,
verstorben,
also relativ zur Bevölkerung natürlich, also welche Landkreise hat's eigentlich am härtesten getroffen.
Sprich, ich äh gehe mal in deine äh Tabelle.
Wirft das ja entsprechend aus, also Todesfälle je 1hundert000, also quasi die Todesfallinzidenz ähm und ja, da haben wir wenig überraschend.
Landkreise wie Görlitz ganz vorne, wo wir also jetzt auf eine Gesamtzahl von knapp 500 kommen. 495.
Also 0,5 Prozent. Der Bevölkerung.
Richtig, ne? Jetzt habe ich keinen Aufbau-One dabei, ne. Also Inzidenz ist ja je hunderttausend. Wenn wir also tausend hätten, dann wär's ein Prozent. Wir haben hier quasi fünfhundert, also null Komma fünf Prozent.
Der Bevölkerung ist an.
Oder mit. Corona verstorben. Das ist schon.
Schon ganz schön viel, finde ich für so einen einen eine eine Todesfallquelle innerhalb eines Zeitraums von äh knapp zwei Jahren.
Jeder, jeder zwei Hundertste, ja in Tschechien habe ich auch gehört äh so gibt's da.
Heftigste Einschläge so Nachbar vom,
mir es wohl jetzt verstorben in meinem Alter 56 Jahre alt, so äh ja,
Ähm also plus äh also in Tschechien ist die Situation grad auch äh wieder außer Kontrolle komplett.
So, da ist äh ja äh.
Schlimmsten,
die Landkreise dies heißt da am meisten betroffen hat jetzt nach Todeszahlen kann man vielleicht mal die Top Ten auch mal runterrasseln, finde ich auch mal ganz interessant.
Also Görlitz halt auf äh Platz äh eins so und bis zu Platz zehn geht's dann so auf null Komma drei fünf Prozent runter. Also auch alles noch ziemlich krass. Das ist also Hildburghausen, Thüringen. Sächsische Schweiz Ost
Erzgebirge Sachsen, Vogtlandkreis in Sachsen, dann das schon hier sehr oft erwähnte Tirschenreuth in Bayern.
Altenburger Land, in Thüringen, Burglandkreis, Sachsen-Anhalt, Zwickau, Sachsen, Suhl, Thüringen,
Ist alles Thüringen, Sachsen, Thüringen, Sachsen, Sachsen und Bayern und Sachsen und Bayern. Also da unten äh das macht einfach mal so die top twenty top thirty wahrscheinlich sogar aus. Ich krieg's hier gar nicht.
Komplett runter. Also was soll man noch dazu sagen?
So, wir sagen jetzt einfach gar nichts mehr dazu.
Sondern schließen den Teil einfach mal ab und ich würde sagen, wir gucken uns mal an, was es eigentlich äh mit unserer Impfkampagne weil,
dem das ja nun wirklich seit äh August alles so deprimierend zurückging, dass ähm,
ja wir auch gar nicht weiter mehr auf die Zahlen geschaut haben und das Ganze so sein totales Tief hatte.
Mitte Oktober ungefähr, also da war einfach das Gesamt-Impfgeschehen so dermaßen äh runtergegangen, es sich überhaupt gar nicht mehr gelohnt hat, darüber zu berichten. Haben wir jetzt so ab Anfang November wieder einen.
50.00 pro Tag, die Gegend, oder? So.
Lass mich schauen.
Ja, aber erst sozusagen, ja. Erstimpfungen, ja ja unter fünfzigtausend und Zweitimpfungen auch so bei fünfzigtausend, so wie ich das dem Grafen zumindest entnehmen.
Ja kriege hier gerade die.
Nächstes.
Fünfzigtausend, meinst du?
Mhm. Na ja, während wir jetzt bei irgendwie im pro Tag, genau.
Pro Tag meinst du, ne? Ähm ein bisschen mehr war's schon, also ging eher so auf hunderttausend äh runter, aber erst.
Okay, erst plus Zweitimpfungen. Okay, also je wir hatten dann genau 50.000 Erst- und irgendwie.
Also mit Boosterimpfung und so weiter war's war's schon mehr als das. Okay äh ich wollt's jetzt eh mal danach äh aufdröseln beziehungsweise mal schauen, wie's derzeit aussieht. Also derzeit gehen die die Impfungen,
enorm nach oben. Wir äh sind jetzt fast auf dem
Niveau äh als es so im Mai richtig zur Sache abging, weil natürlich jetzt viele Leute losrennen und sich ihre Boosterimpfungen holen und die jetzt im Prinzip auch dran sind. Also wir haben jetzt genau den Zeitpunkt erreicht,
wo all die Leute äh sechs Monate, vor sechs Monaten ähm ihren.
Ihre Zweitimpfung erhalten haben im Juni und jetzt quasi dran sind mit dem neuen fünf Monate äh Regime und dementsprechend machen natürlich jetzt die Booster-Impfung,
den Großteil aus, ne? Ganz klar. Trotz alledem gab es so ein bisschen Lichtblick,
wir schauen ja eigentlich, eigentlich wollen wir ja Erstimpfungen sehen, ne? Also wollen,
Zweitimpfungen. Alle möglichen Impfungen sehen, aber das ist ja eigentlich so ein bisschen die Zahl, die die ganze Zeit so äh traurig war
Wir haben also derzeit äh so einen ganz kleinen Peak, der aber auch schon wieder am Main zurückzugehen von ungefähr 0,1 Prozent der Bevölkerung, die sich jetzt erst impfen lässt.
Das reicht natürlich hinten und vorne nicht, ne? Also wir brauchen sehr viel mehr, weil wir haben da noch quasi dreißig Prozent offen. Davon müssten so mindestens so zehn bis zwanzig Prozent ähm auch wirklich,
mal dazukommen. Wir könnten also eher so was wie Ein-Prozent pro Tag gebrauchen, aber na ja gut, davon sind wir noch weit entfernt. Man kann aber schon sagen
jetzt die Situation seit Anfang des Monats zumindest dazu Leute dazu gebracht hat, sich
impfen zu lassen. Also die Erstimpfbereitschaft hat sich quasi verdoppelt innerhalb dieses Monats. Nur sieht's gerade nicht so aus, als ob,
dass ein äh bleibender Trend ist.
Du hast dann glaube ich auch online auf Twitter ein bisschen ähm darüber philosophiert, ob wir denn eigentlich genug Boosterimpfungen nachliefern
können im Verhältnis zu dem Bedarf. Wenn man jetzt davon ausgeht, dass die neue Definition lautet, nach sechs Monaten ist der Impfschutz nichts mehr wert
In Israel ist das ja auch offiziell so, dass man also nicht mehr als vollständig und damit ausreichend geimpft gilt, nach sechs Monaten, hatten wir ja hier erst mal das Drama.
Man sich jetzt vor sechs Monaten gar nicht äh impfen lassen konnte, also nach dem Maßstab
sozusagen ganz viele Leute auf einmal rausfallen. Jetzt ist das Regime ein bisschen gelockert worden. Offiziell ist es fünf Monate und es gibt halt viele Impfstellen, die es nicht so äh genau nehmen und auch Leute nach drei oder vier Monaten impfen.
So wie ich das hier den äh Grafiken
entnehme und äh im Übrigen, ich nehme das jetzt nicht mehr in meinen eigenen Grafiken, ich hatte damit äh aufhören müssen, nachdem sich das Datenformat hart geändert hat und dann hatte ich irgendwie keinen Bock mehr bei fallenden Zahlen mir das wieder neu zu erarbeiten.
Bin jetzt hier auf einem andere Auswertung gegangen, die ich schon vor längerer Zeit mal verlinkt habe.
Das äh ist das äh Werk von Daniel, der das schon lange macht und vor allem auch so eine Simulation damit eingebaut hat, also so eine Voraussage über wo, die man denn jetzt hin, wenn alles sich so entwickelt und man kann tausend Sachen einstellen. Auf jeden Fall sind hier noch ein paar Auswertungen dazugekommen, die sehr viel mehr
meinen ähneln und deswegen kann ich das jetzt wieder für meine eigenen Analysen mitbenutzen. Ähm werde ich äh entsprechend verlinken. Ja und das äh
dem kann man auch entnehmen, was du quasi der aktuelle Booster-Bedarf wäre. Man sieht es also derzeit mehr geboostert wird als der Bedarf ist.
Holen ein bisschen auf.
Aber äh nicht wirklich,
Vielfaches, sondern es sind halt ungefähr 50 Prozent ähäh mehr äh sagen die geboostert werden als die jetzt neu hinzukommen.
Insofern ja passt das.
Also quasi aus diesem vollen Impfschutz rausfallen würden jetzt nach dieser Definition.
Genau. Also immerhin, ja, also es sind sozusagen mehr, die sich boostern äh lassen, aber wir brauchen ja nur in den Nachrichten äh Wald zu schauen und wir sehen halt, das Problem ist nach wie vor,
Impfzentren sind geschlossen worden. Es gibt die Kapazitäten nicht, teilweise höre ich jetzt auch schon wieder, dass es schon wieder Impfstoffmangel gibt, also im Sinne von er ist nicht vor Ort, obwohl es ihn ja eigentlich gibt. Also wir haben eigentlich keinen Impfstoffmangel, nur,
funktioniert die Logistik gerade nicht. Die angehende Bundesregierung will ja jetzt reagieren mit einem Krisenstab.
Nur sagen kann yay, Krisenstab, geil nach zwei Jahren.
Mhm.
Okay, danke, Merkel.
Warum hatten wir das nicht schon äh vorher. Ähm man folgt hier offenbar dem italienischen Modell. Denn die Italiener haben ja ihre Interesse Impfkampagne.
Quasi militärisch organisieren lassen, die haben sich halt ein Logistiker aus dem Militär geholt, der das wohl,
ziemlich ordentlich angeschoben hat und genau diesem Modell folgt man jetzt auch in Deutschland. Ich habe jetzt den Namen grad nicht parat von dem äh Herrn, der da im Gespräch ist. Aber äh auch hier gibt's wohl jemanden, der
das mit der Logistik mal gelernt hat oder zumindest bewiesen hat, dass er so eine Kette kriegt, weil das will man ja dann irgendwie, weil.
Ich bin wirklich nicht unbedingt jetzt so derjenige, der besonders sagen wir mal ein besonderer Freund des Militärs ist, aber man unterstellt dem Militär ja dann doch zumindest ein paar Sachen.
Die sich also mit diesen Sachen beschäftigen, dass zumindest so was wie Nachschublieferungen und so weiter schon so zum Kerngeschäft gehören soll.
Ja ich also gut ich weiß nicht wie es
mittlerweile ist aber äh zu meiner Bundeswehrzeit Mitte der Achtziger. Äh so hatte ich nicht das Gefühl, nur um ein Beispiel zu nennen, wie dort der Nachschub
organisiert war beziehungsweise die Regeln. Also es gab eine Regel, dass halt auf
Lenkachsen äh keine runderneuerten Reifen äh gefahren werden dürfen, aber es gab halt im Nachschub grundsätzlich nur
runderneuerte Reifen, so. Was dann dazu führte, dass wir halt von den Neufahrzeugen oder von denen, wo die Reifen noch nicht
Originalreifen noch nicht abgefahren waren, dann halt gewechselt haben beziehungsweise ich dann für die sogenannte Prüfstufe C, das ist der TÜV
äh beim beim Bund dann äh sagen die die nicht runderneuerten Reifen von einem Fahrzeug, was schon aus der Prüfung war an das neue Fahrzeug angeschraubt war, was hat
was dann in die Prüfung gehen sollte, so. Ja, also
so viel irgendwie zur zur Bundeswehr äh äh Logistik. Also ich hoffe, ich hoffe das Beste, ich will dem Mann nichts Böses, aber meine persönlichen Erfahrungen äh sind schon eher.
Das Militär normalerweise so ziemlich der Gipfel der Ineffizienz.
Äh äh sind. Ich hätte das ja eher, weiß ich nicht, vielleicht Amazon mit der Impfkampagne beauftragt oder so,
ich meine, die kriegen es hin irgendwie in fünf Stunden.
Irgendwie alles nach Hause äh zu lief oder oder ja äh irgendwie am nächsten Tag äh so im Prinzip alles Mögliche zu liefern. Insofern äh keine Ahnung. Und ich weiß auch ja ich weiß auch nicht warum, ja gut
okay, hat vielleicht einen anderen Grund. Zur Selbstimpfung oder so. Ich meine, den Star-Track haben sie immer irgendwie so nette äh ja äh warum kann ich sowas nicht auf Amazon äh bestellen? Ja gut, gibt
wahrscheinlich gute Gründe dafür bei irgendwelchen.
Sich dann 50 Stück von den Dingern reinhauen würden. Wahrscheinlich nach dem Motto viel hilft viel oder so und dann ist es auch nicht dokumentiert und ja und dann wird's warm und so. Also insofern schon vielleicht schon okay, aber trotzdem äh.
Okay, wissen wir nicht,
aber ich finde es schon mal gut, dass man jetzt endlich mal auf die Idee gekommen ist, wie wär's denn, wenn wir einfach mal so ein Team aufsetzen, was sich einfach nur spezifisch mit diesem Problem beschäftigt?
Anstatt dass irgendwie durch die Länder und irgendwie und ich meine eine Erfahrung haben wir gemacht, so wie es bisher war.
Lief's Scheiße.
Deutlich suboptimal.
Ja, also es war einfach mal kann man kann man keine Loblieder drauf singen. Das ist ja klar
in einzelnen Impfzentren ist mit Sicherheit große Arbeit geleistet worden. Ich habe da auch teilweise Einblicke äh gewonnen. Da sind viele engagierte Menschen, die die alles
gut können, ja, die aber dann natürlich auch an die Grenze kommen.
Ihr äh Personal gekündigt wird, wenn sie umziehen müssen in andere Orte und quasi ihre ganze Logistik neu aufbauen müssen, wenn Impfzentren,
komplett geschlossen werden oder in äh bestimmten Bereichen einfach überhaupt nicht existieren oder auch wie hier in Berlin.
Alle im Westen sind ja und nix im Osten und so weiter und so fort. Also das ist äh eine totale Katastrophe und das muss natürlich jetzt überkommen werden und wenn sie jetzt so einen Krisenstab genau das leistet, dass in den nächsten zwei, drei Monaten da,
Abhilfe geschaffen wird, sage ich, Hallelujah, wunderbar, schön, hätten wir auch früher haben können, aber gut, dass es jetzt da ist.
Also der Bedarf war, sage ich mal, wenn man sich die Kurven jetzt so anguckt, war eigentlich ab August absehbar.
In äh welchen äh Mengen und Umfang äh äh geboostert werden muss. Äh so. Das war halt, wie gesagt, das ist seit August
hätte das eigentlich jedem klar sein müssen, aber so ja.
Oder können, sagen wir mal so, können und und jedem, der da in Verantwortung steht, müssen eigentlich. So.
Spätestens nachdem das halt in ähm.
Spätestens seitdem das in äh Israel sich klar gezeigt hat, dass das Boostern erforderlich ist. Und das stand ja auch nie,
nie so, dass man da angenommen hat, das wäre nicht so. Soll man wusste es halt nur nicht, aber ist jetzt auch keine neue,
Erkenntnis, dass Impfstoffe, die jetzt nicht klassische Lebendimpfstoffe sind, nochmal nach äh geboostert werden müssen, das das ist bei anderen Impfungen auch so gewesen.
Und mein gut, im Juli, ich habe mir nochmal also äh äh Drosten hatte ja,
wie getwittert auch noch mal ein Link auf dem Bericht aus Juli vom vom RKI auf,
auf so ein Epidemiologisches Bulleter und,
Hatte ich dann mal geguckt, was denn da drin steht. Da stand jetzt im Juli noch nichts konkretes äh äh drüber. Da stand jetzt nicht und im Übrigen müssen wir uns irgendwie aufs sondern da stand halt nur drin ja und.
Ähm äh
wahrscheinlich, je nachdem wie sich Varianten entwickelt und wie schnell die Impfstoffwirkung nachlässt, äh äh müssten wir wahrscheinlich Boostern ähm und äh wir werden aber auf jeden Fall äh anziehende Zahlen kriegen, weil
Mittlerweile gibt's wohl so etwas auch wie offizielle Zahlen für die Saisonalität
und das sinnvoll ungefähr 0,4 auf den R-Wert geht man jetzt äh davon aus, ist der Unterschied zwischen jetzt Sommer und und Winter. Das waren jetzt die letzte Zahl.
Ähm die ich gehört hatte. Das heißt, es war einfach absehbar, dass selbst wenn sich nichts ändert äh der R-Wert auf jeden Fall um 0,4 ansteigen.
Äh wird. So und das ist auch dann, was wir halt jetzt gesehen äh haben und äh ja,
Äh gut, hoffen wir, dass es dass es irgendwie dass das vielleicht jetzt,
bei Welle vier äh oder nach Welle vier vielleicht irgendeinen Lerneffekt da ist, aber ich ich seh's noch nicht äh so richtig. Ich sehe es noch nicht und ähm.
Ja auf jeden Fall würden wir definitiv äh bis.
Also eigentlich soll ja bis was heißt bis Ende äh Februar bis Ende Januar sollten irgendwie alle wohl äh durchgeboostert ähm,
sein, aber wenn wir das schaffen wollen, ja da muss da muss man noch muss jetzt noch ein bisschen
zugelegt äh werden, weil da bis Januar, Ende Januar kommen eben auch noch äh deutlich mehr Leute äh dazu. Also
die große Welle oder der große Berg äh äh kommt halt noch jetzt von Leuten, wo der Impfschutz nachlässt.
Ja, da kommen wir natürlich jetzt auch schon zu unserem nächsten Kapitel, nämlich wir reden jetzt gerade nur von Boostern.
Ja? Aber äh was auch debattiert wird und in den letzten zwei Wochen sehr viel lebendiger, als sie's ehrlich gesagt erwartet hätte ähm ja ist eine Impfpflicht in Deutschland.
Der Gerüchteküche glauben darf zumindest für bestimmte Berufe, sprich die Pflegeberufe mit Sicherheit kommt.
Und für den Rest der Bevölkerung würde ich sagen.
Macht es auf mich so den Eindruck, als ob wir da auch schon so eine siebzigprozentige Wahrscheinlichkeit gerade entwickeln, dass das kommt, weil wenn's nicht kommt.
Muss sich ja irgendjemand politisch für die Auswirkungen äh der aktuellen Welle verantwortlich machen und das wäre dann zwangsläufig die neue Regierung und ich habe so ein bisschen so den Eindruck.
Während die FDP in den letzten Monaten ja nicht unbedingt gerade so den Eindruck gemacht
äh haben, als wären sie jetzt so die Vorfront der Wissenschaftsfreunde, was äh die Coronapandemie,
trifft, um's mal ein bisschen zurückhaltend zu formulieren. Waren die Grünen immer so ein bisschen in der Zwickmühle und die SPD, na ja, weiß man halt immer nicht so genau, wo sie so stehen. Und jetzt habe ich so den Eindruck in der ganzen Debatte ist mittlerweile klar, Impfpflicht,
eigentlich unumgänglich und ich empfinde das auch so. Ich denke, dass dass wir jetzt an so einem Punkt angekommen sind, wo.
Nicht offen, also wo man nicht so den Eindruck hat, dass wir die Impflücke anders geschlossen bekommen, als durch eine Impfpflicht.
Ja also nicht, dass das auf jeden Fall zu 100 Prozent erfolgreich sein wird, aber ich sehe jetzt keine andere Maßnahme, die man noch ergreifen kann. Hm deswegen äh könnte der Impfbedarf noch etwas höher sein bis Februar.
Ja das das ist das ist in der Tat so, da gibt's ja da gibt's noch ähm so.
Ähm ein Dutzend Millionen Leute, die noch zwei, die ihre ersten zwei Dosen, also wahrscheinlich ja nochmal was, zwanzig,
Millionen Dosen, Extra, ein äh da nochmal hoffentlich dann dann für rausgehen. Also meine Haltung äh zur.
Impfpflicht ist die. Also ich finde äh Impfpflicht für bestimmte Berufsgruppen.
Eigentlich einen no Brainer. Also es gibt für viele Berufsgruppen, ich meine Seeleute, Soldaten und so äh oder auch bestimmte Auslandsreisen und so. Es ist klar und eigentlich
werden halt auch ähm so in den in den Gesundheitsberufen, also wie ich das kenne
so lassen sich normalerweise bei bei den meisten Krankheiten so die,
Pfleger, äh die ich kenne zumindest auch regelmäßig gegen alles Mögliche impfen oder ihren Impfschutz.
Aktualisieren. Ich dachte eigentlich vor Corona, das wäre völlig normal. Äh das ist eigentlich so was gäbe in den Gesundheitsberufen, wie eine wie eine.
Pflicht, weil äh ich finde das schon so ein bisschen irre. Ich meine, das Problem, was wir natürlich jetzt haben, ist
dass die Leute da äh äh alle eh ausgezehrt äh sind und dass dort eh Personalknappheit besteht und das ist natürlich jetzt Angst hat das dann so zehn, zwanzig Prozent oder so dann vielleicht rausgehen äh weil sie sich nicht impfen
lassen äh wollen, dass ein bisschen die Befürchtung, aber ich finde, äh muss man sagen, sorry, aber da müssten wir jetzt einmal durch.
Und äh vielleicht führt das dann einfach auch zu einer nachhaltigen Veränderung äh sage ich mal,
dahingehend, dass dass man da dann dafür sorgt, dass man generell jetzt nicht nur was was covid angeht äh sondern generell halt äh da einen in den Gesundheitsberufen, den anderen Berufen ein vernünftiges ähm
Impfmanagement äh betreibt, äh sage ich mal, staatlicher äh Salz, da wo,
erhöhtes äh Risiko besteht. Was jetzt eine allgemeine Impfpflicht äh angeht sozusagen für jeden Bürger. Ich weiß gar nicht, was das was Österreich jetzt, was plant denn da Österreicher auch nur für Berufs oder für jeden?
Für alle, ja. Ähm so würde ich sagen ja kann man auch machen, hatten wir in der Vergangenheit auch, hat funktioniert,
So äh für für verschiedene Krankheiten. Ich meine, das gab's gab's halt,
zur Kaiserzeit schon unter den Nazis wurde das dann aufgeweicht. Die Impfpflicht, aber dann sowohl in der DDR als auch in der Bundesrepublik gab's dann
verschiedene Impfpflichten, zum Beispiel Pocken war halt ein Thema, das ist
gelungen, die dann auszurotten äh auch und so ein paar andere äh Krankheiten,
auch äh gut man ist davon dann nach und nach jetzt abgekommen. Äh ich glaube seit neunzig oder so äh gibt's jetzt nicht wirklich mehr eine eine Impfpflicht, wenn ich da richtig also jetzt gibt's halt länger,
äh keine mehr. Aber ich sehe jetzt auch keinen zwingenden Grund ähm warum das jetzt nicht der Fall äh sein,
sollte, so. Also ich find's jetzt auch nicht schrecklich, aber wir sind halt heutzutage jetzt ein bisschen, ja, weiß ich nicht, verwöhnter äh.
In anderen Ländern, ich kann sie jetzt grad nicht benennen, aber ich habe einen äh Bericht dazu gelesen, wo äh das in der Pflege durchgesetzt wurde, waren dann die Kündigungsquoten.
Eher so im äh Sub-Prozent-Bereich. Das hat sich am Ende überhaupt nicht durchgesetzt und ich will äh auch sagen,
können jetzt halt auch einfach keine ungeimpften Leute in in diesen Berufen gebrauchen.
Also die Situation ist da sowieso schlecht. Die muss ohnehin verbessert werden. Also ähm selbst wenn man das jetzt nicht mit einrechnet, ist die Situation äh an der Stelle schon total verbesserungswürdig.
Gerade zu erforderlich, dass hier auch über ganz andere Maßnahmen nachgedacht wird, wie diese Berufszweige wieder attraktiv werden.
Aber sicherlich nicht, indem man die Leute dadurch anzieht mit Company-Pflegeberufe, da musst du dich nicht impfen lassen. Also äh das kann's ja nun auch nicht sein.
In der Tat ein bisschen bekloppt. Ich meine, eine andere Geschichte vielleicht noch. Wir hatten zwar, glaube ich, beim letzten Mal schon angesprochen, aber äh sagen die Frage, so äh
Wann wer sollte sich denn wann eigentlich jetzt jetzt lassen nach nach wie langer äh Zeit und wie äh stark fällt denn jetzt äh die
Schutzwirkung nach nach welcher Zeit und da halt auch ein.
Lass uns das gleich noch mal äh besprechen. Wir wollen ja auch noch mal kurz über äh dies STIKO äh sprechen. Aber ähm.
Sind wir fertig jetzt quasi mit dieser Impfpflicht äh Debatte, also wir sind beide der Meinung, sollte kommen äh und ich bin der Meinung, wird kommen. Du bist der Meinung, wird kommen.
Ähm ja ich äh also für alle bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher, für Berufsgruppen bin ich mir relativ äh äh sicher äh so. Wahrscheinlich mit dann auch irgendwelchen komischen Ausnahmeregelungen natürlich wieder und so, aber.
Aber du bist der Meinung, sie sollte eigentlich für alle kommen.
Ja, also das heißt, sollte das äh sagen, dass äh.
Wenn du jetzt Bundeskanzler wärst, wärst du dafür.
Mhm. Äh ja.
Gut, mehr wollte ich auch gar nicht wissen, weil das ist ja äh das einzige, was entscheidend ist, ja. Was wäre, wenn wir jetzt äh das entscheiden äh könnten, der Rest ist dann Debatte in den Kommentaren, aber das ist.
Mhm mhm.
Meiner Meinung nach kann man jetzt eigentlich nichts anderes tun als alles dafür zu tun.
Diese scheiß Pandemie zu Ende geht und es wird nicht alleine nur mit dem Impfen getan sein, aber ohne das Impfen wird es halt auch nix.
So, sondern dann werden wir eine fünfte Welle haben, dann werden wir äh weiterhin alle möglichen Beschränkungen haben, die wir alle nicht haben wollen. So, also tun wir bitte das Maximum.
Ja, ich habe auch äh tatsächlich, wie gesagt, meine Meinung dazu geändert. Ich war eigentlich eher auch skeptisch
so ein bisschen bislang gegenüber einer allgemeinen Impfpflicht so, weil ich eigentlich eher so ja kein Freund von Zwangsmaßnahmen bin und äh gerade auch im äh also da ist halt in der Vergangenheit einfach auch.
Moment, das ist keine Zwangsmaßnahme.
Ich rede nicht von einem Impfzwang. Und ich finde, das sollte man in dieser Debatte auch tunlichst auseinanderhalten, weil das ist was anderes.
Okay, was ist da jetzt für dich der Unterschied äh.
Der Unterschied ist, dass eine Impfpflicht dich verpflichtet, dich impfen zu lassen, wenn du's nicht tust, dann.
Strafe droht, ja, aber es kommt jetzt keiner vorbei und bindet die aufn Stuhl und und.
Okay, okay. Ja, ja, mhm.
Ja, das ist das ist ein Impfzwang und ich rede nicht von einem Impfzwang, sondern jemand, der äh sich nicht impfen lässt zu einem bestimmten Stichtag.
Der äh muss dann halt leider auf die Ausübung seines Berufs äh verzichten äh et cetera.
Ja und wer wer dann äh okay und wer die Strafe dann nicht zahlt, kommt allerdings früher oder später in Erzwingungshaft. Äh so, das ist dann also okay. Ja. Nun gut, ja. Mhm.
Ich meine, wir machen das mit wir machen das bei Schwarzfahrern.
Mhm.
So ja das das ist der Level auf dem wir jetzt gerade irgendwie äh äh diskutieren und noch noch noch andere äh Dinge. Also Schwarzfahrer, ich weiß nicht, ist jetzt glaube ich auch gerade
irgendwie äh ein bisschen zurückgefahren worden, aber das war so bis vor Kurzem war das so der normale Modus. Du äh hast einen Tick in der Straßenbahn nicht bezahlt. Du bist nicht in der Lage, das danach zu bezahlen, dann kommst du danach in eine Erzwingungshaft.
Ersatz- oder Ersatzfreiheitsstrafe äh wahrscheinlich.
Ja, nee, es heißt glaube ich auch so oder so. Ich kann nur einfach sagen, in der Pandemie ist mir Schwarzfahren gerade scheißegal.
Ist mir völlig Wumpe. Ja, da geht die Welt nicht äh von unter. Aber von sich nicht impfen lassen.
Geht die Welt unter. 14 Leute geben die sich dann mit allen möglichen Rechtsstreitigkeiten und dem Entzug von Zugriff und so weiter äh und untertauchen und so weiter dagegen wehren werden.
Wird's geben. Mhm. Werden wir von allen Leuten Geld bekommen. So, nein, wenn wir nicht äh wird es die Impfquote erhöhen mhm. Wird es. Ausreichen, weiß ich nicht, aber wir müssen das ausprobieren.
Ich wollte eigentlich jetzt noch erklären, warum ich meine Meinung dazu geändert,
habe einen Grund, äh nämlich warum ich auch meine Meinung geändert habe, ist, weil auch wiederum durch, ich sage mal, staatlich sanktionierte Maßnahmen und Gelder äh Impfgegner produziert wurden, äh nämlich
durch Förderung von Homöopathie. Ja? Ähm,
dadurch, dass halt der Gesetzgeber das zugelassen hat und viele Krankenkassen sich dafür entschieden haben, äh sowohl,
homöopathische Medikamente in Anführungszeichen als auch homöopathische Therapien äh ganz oder zu 80 Prozent äh zu finanzieren. Es gibt da gewisse Unterschiede so. Ähm.
Hat sich jetzt äh äh raus äh das hat sich jetzt rausgestellt, dass halt äh oh Wunder unter Leuten, die halt auf Homöopathie
stehen. Äh die Zahl der Impfverweigerer oder Impfgegner besonders hoch ist. Ja äh und.
Wenn man sich das jetzt überlegt was da jetzt passiert also was sagen siehst ja immer so schön so Homöopathie äh das wirkt nicht über den Placebo Effekt hinaus aber ich fürchte es gibt halt
eben,
diese unangenehme Nebenwirkung von homöopathischen Arznei, dass nämlich die Leute äh dann äh sich nicht impfen lassen oder zu Impfgegnern werden und zwar.
Auch deswegen, weil äh man zum einen dadurch, wenn die Krankenkasse das bezahlt,
dass äh dem dem Ganzen einen Anstrich von Seriösität, ja weil oh wenn der Staat und die Kassen, die ja sonst so knausrig sind äh irgendwie das Finanzier, da muss ja was dran sein, ja, da muss ja was dran sein.
Jahr für die Kassen natürlich klar, äh die denken sich halt na ja gut die ganzen.
Ähm jetzt Hypochonder oder so, die äh irgendwie können wir damit wunderbar abfertigen und der Placebo-Effekt ist ja auch was wert und am Ende ist ja viel billiger als äh wenn wir,
da jetzt wirklich was was machen so. Ähm.
Insofern kann ich so ein bisschen die die Sicht der Kassen zwar nachvollziehen, aber woran wahrscheinlich niemand gedacht hat, ist, dass äh ja, sie dadurch eigentlich
Betrug Vorschub leisten, dass sie, dass sie ihre Versicherten.
Betrügen und halt eine Branche aus Neppern, Schleppern und Bauerfängern äh mit Geld finanzieren, die natürlich für sich dann wiederum auch Marketing betreiben und Lobbyismus betreiben, ja? Das heißt,
im Endeffekt
äh haben die Versicherten beziehungsweise die Kassen und die Politik da eine Maschinerie in Gang gesetzt oder oder befeuert. Es ist ja jetzt nichts Neues äh Homöopathie. Aber dadurch, dass das jetzt
äh man in dem Maße staatlich sanktioniert ist, äh so produziert der Staat faktisch Impfgegner, so. Das war
Also erstens sollte man das natürlich abstellen. Ich hatte da jetzt auch.
Fohlen, ich meine das Einfachste ist, äh wenn man das nicht mitfinanzieren möchte und feststellt, dass die eigene Kasse eigene Krankenkasse äh sowas finanziert, äh kann man halt relativ
einfach innerhalb von ein oder zwei Monaten jetzt uns eine gesetzliche ist ähm jederzeit in eine,
andere Krankenkasse wechseln, die dann das nicht finanziert. Klar, gibt noch andere Aspekte beim Kassenwechsel, die man vielleicht beachten muss, wie es die überhaupt sonst so übernehmen, aber.
Was das kostet, aber äh ich sage mal grundsätzlich finde ich, ist das ein Punkt, den man gar nicht äh oft genug,
betonen kann, dass äh wir uns die hohe Zahl von äh ja Impfgegnern auch selbst gebacken haben, ja, mit mit diesem fahrlässigen
ja Homöopathie, äh wo du äh gefördere.
Du du zielst jetzt nur auf die Krankenkassen ab, ich würde noch einen zweiten Aspekt nennen, fast noch wichtiger finde. Ähm nämlich.
Während ich den für die Krankenkassen noch ein ein Funken Mitleid habe, weil die ja sozusagen um Mitglieder werben, ja und
äh einfach sehen, dass diese Leute äh äh bereit sind äh an so etwas ihren Wechsel festzumachen, ist für sie aber jetzt unterm Strich finanziell
nicht so das Volumen hat, dass es jetzt wirklich so ein Problem ist mit das mitzufinanzieren, ja? Äh ist das Kernproblem, dass das.
Homöopathie immer noch eine rechtliche Ausnahme.
Gewährt wird in Deutschland als es da halt in den 70er Jahren mal von der SPD eingeführt wurde ähm die im Prinzip sagt,
Ihr müsst nicht belegen, dass das wirkt. Das Zeug.
Während alle anderen Medikamente das sehr wohl müssen. Das heißt, man kann sich irgendwas irgendeinen Scheiß ausdenken. Ja, sagen hier, das habe ich jetzt irgendwie eine Million Mal
verdünnt und es enthält eigentlich nur noch Wasser, damit's schmeckt, mache ich noch ein bisschen Zucker rein und das verkaufe ich jetzt für 20 Euro und das kann ich halt einfach mal so anbieten, aber ich muss niemals nachweisen, dass das wirkt. Das ist halt einfach genau dieser Faktor Wissenschaftsungläubigkeit.
Kristalltherapie ja.
All dieser ganze Unsinn, ja, äh alles, was von der Krankenkasse bezahlt wird, muss einen nachgewiesenen.
Nutzen haben, Punkt. Das ist einfach die,
Geschichte, die wo sich jetzt auch mal die Grünen vielleicht mal überlegen müssen, ob sie äh das nicht mal durchsetzen gegenüber sicherlich den Widerstand bestimmter Teile ihrer Wählerschaft, weil sonst ähm geht das ewig so weiter.
Ja, ja, ja
interessant noch in dem Zusammenhang, weil wir bei den Grünen sind, habe ich ja auch geguckt äh weil ich hatte ja auch so ein bisschen so einen satirischen Shred neulich geschrieben ähm dass äh man vielleicht äh irgendwie dann doch so
das mit Gott versuchen sollte das vielleicht
einfach, dass die Leute nicht begreifen müssen, warum, sondern einfach nur, weil Gott ihnen sagt, dass sie sich impfen lassen äh sollen. Also müssen sie jetzt nicht verstehen, sondern weil Gottes Wege sind unergründlich und so, aber äh äh ja.
Äh sagt, lasst euch äh äh lasst euch impfen und äh irgendwie macht die Rituale, bedeckt
eure Münder und Nasen irgendwie mit Tuch und äh ja äh seid reinlich so all die Dinge so
äh es war ja ein bisschen jetzt äh halbsatirisch äh gemeint, aber.
Zufällig auch nachgeguckt was empfehlen denn jetzt so die offiziellen Vertreter oder Botschaften Gottes eher äh von Gott auf Erden die die Kirchen äh äh nämlich zu dem Thema und,
Offiziell haben sowohl die katholische Kirche als auch äh so die evangelischen Bischöfe rufen halt alle zur Impfung.
Auf. Auch der Papst hat sich dazu geäußert. Also genau hier also Papst sagt, lasst euch impfen. Äh so ist es halt äh ja eine Christenpflicht äh sich sich impfen.
Äh äh zu lassen aus verschiedenen Gründen. Das ist einmal ein Akt der Nächstenliebe und Barmherzigkeit, weil ihr damit eurer nächsten schützt. Also insofern die Kirche ist auch äh schon voll
auf dem Trip unterwegs also sei ich jetzt nicht von einem Atheisten wie mir, sondern wie gesagt, glaubt dem Papst äh ja.
Es hilft aber in Ostdeutschland überhaupt nicht.
Nee, stimmt. Ja und in Tschechien erst recht nicht, äh weil da sind nämlich zweiundneunzig Prozent äh Atheisten, aber,
ja was
auch kritisiert wurde in in Deutschland war, dass zwei Jahre die Kirchenoberen und so sich sich äußern, aber das von der Kanzel äh aus wohl relativ wenig Aufrufe oder direkte Ansprache an die Gläubigen erfolgt,
äh ist, keine Ahnung, ob das jetzt allzu viel geändert hätte, aber ich meine auch grade
Kirchen so als Plätze äh so wo sich Leute versammeln ähm ja äh äh könnten sicherlich auch auch mehr tun. Aber gut, das ist äh.
War jetzt nur so ein so ein äh Rand-Aspekt.
Wollen wir jetzt noch noch kurz zu der sozusagen wie lange äh Impfungen wirken, wenn wir den Blog noch machen, bevor wir da mit den Impfungen durch sind oder.
Hätten wir noch äh kurz. Also ich meine, da ist ja ähm.
Tut sich ja so ein bisschen was an der Front, ne? Also die letzte Woche war auch ein bisschen davon geprägt, dass äh die STIKO doch ordentlich Feuer bekommen hat und siehe da sogar der Mertens äh hat jetzt.
So ein bisschen anklingen lassen, dass es vielleicht alles dann doch nicht so optimal gelaufen ist.
Allerdings auch gleich wieder Öl ins Feuer gegossen, indem man dann erzählt hat, dass er ja irgendwie seine Kinder oder seine, weiß nicht, Enkel oder was auch immer, äh jetzt äh nicht empfehlen würde zu äh impfen oder weiß gar nicht, ob er da irgendwie das äh Entscheidungsrecht
genießt. Wie auch immer. Ähm mittlerweile ist die Drittlimpfung offiziell auch empfohlen von der STIKO für alle ab 18.
Warum auch immer ab 8zehn? Warum nicht alle? Also.
Bleibt äh nach wie vor ein äh Mysterium und ähm ja schön, dass sie ein paar Fehler äh einräumen. Ich denke mal, die haben jetzt auch ordentlich Flagg bekommen, denn.
Das war alles nicht so hilfreich, ja, weil diese Wahrnehmung äh zeigt sich ja auch, dass auch die Ärzte interessanterweise auch nicht so richtig perfekt äh informiert zu sein scheint, ne. Also da gibt's dann zum Beispiel immer wieder dieses dieses Ding,
dann äh Patienten so, ja wie's mit impfen und dann so ja nee die STIKO empfiehlt das ja nicht.
Deswegen können wir das nicht tun wegen der Haftung, weil da haften wir ja. Stimmt alles nicht.
Ein zugelassener Impfstoff ist, in dieser Coronapandemie, also es geht jetzt konkret um Corona-Impfung.
Klar, wenn die Stickode das nicht empfiehlt, dann übernimmt das das Land nicht. Dann übernimmt es aber der Bund.
Das ist äh das Ding,
und tatsächlich kann man wohl ähm Ärzte auch äh anbringen. Ich habe hier ein,
schönen äh Tweet, den ich äh verlinke, ähm
Zurückweisung beim Booster wegen nicht erreichen der sechs Monate darf heute nicht mehr vorkommen. Ich habe ein Musterschreiben entworfen mit dem der Arzt die Ärztin auf äh die mit der Zurückweisung entstehende Haftung hingewiesen wird.
Sich dann noch weigert, haftet für Schäden. Ähm,
ist so im Prinzip so etwas formaler äh Brief, der sich hier auf die Verordnung zum Anspruch auf Schutzimpfungen et cetera verweist, kann man äh sich mal ab äh tippen und äh gegebenenfalls noch erste Überzeugungen leisten. Also,
insgesamt,
dieser ganze Ärzte äh Bereich, Hausärztebereich ein bisschen suboptimal eingebunden in alles. Da sind die Impfzentren doch deutlich unkomplizierter, auch wenn die halt teilweise eben auch diese äh unsäglichen Vorgaben Bezug auf die Zeit
bekommen haben.
So Booster-Impfung. Wem nützt es denn eigentlich wie viel? Und so.
Ja. Ähm also hm
fangen wir vielleicht mal an so erstmal nochmal nochmal generell. Also ich habe einmal immer diese Grafik, wo.
Dann äh die Frage, wie lange wirken Impfungen und welche Impfungen so, sprich äh was wäre so der der der Zeitpunkt äh um sich Boostern äh zu lassen
und das hängt halt sehr stark auch von dem Impfstoff ab, den man erhalten hat. Also äh.
Man kann sagen, jemand der Astra Sinnika
erhalten hat, äh sollte sich eigentlich schon nach zwei Monaten Boostern lassen, ja, nach der nach der
Impfung, weil nach ein bis zwei Monaten ist Astra Seneca schon von 70 auf 50Prozent runter. Das
ist eine Größenordnung, äh wo Biontech erst in vier bis sechs Monaten äh runter ist. Also Biontech
hält der Schutz im Mittel,
so äh bis vier Monate noch ganz okay, aber nach vier Monaten äh geht's dann äh rapide
runter, um dann bei ja im äh nach vier bis sechs Monaten bei nur noch siebenundvierzig Prozent äh zu sein. Ja, dass man also quasi da, wo man ja, mit
nur Astra ähm
nach zwei Monaten äh ist. So, also eigentlich Biontech würde ich sagen, so ab vier Monaten,
Pur-Astrasinnika nach zwei Monaten aus meiner Sicht wäre der richtige äh äh Zeitpunkt. Ähm.
Bei äh Moderna ähm hat man äh da allerdings äh ja noch ein
ticken äh mehr äh Zeit, also da kann man dann auch äh ich sage mal sechs, sieben, acht Monate
ungefähr äh ist der Impfschutz äh dann nach eher sechs, sieben Monaten immer noch bei sechzigProzent äh im im Mittel. Das heißt, da kann man ein, zwei Monate,
länger äh warten, wenn man halt moderner hatte und interessanterweise, was auch ein bisschen unheimlich ist, äh die Kombination Astra Senica und Biontech, die halt auch
sehr viele erhalten haben. Äh da ist es so, dass äh nach
vier Monaten die Wirkung wieder anzusteigen scheint äh zumindest statistisch gesehen. Keine Ahnung wieso, weshalb, warum.
Aber mit der Combo aus Astra Sinnika und äh äh und äh ja Biontech
man äh oder Biontech moderner. Ist egal, ist man genauso gut wie äh zweimal die volle Dosis äh moderner. Also es ist, liegt praktisch fast noch.
70 Prozent die äh der Schutz nach nach sechs Monaten
so rum. Insofern yay aber äh warum das? Das ist unklar und ein anderes Ding ist, dass halt bei Astra Sinnig hat er sich nach vier bis sechs Monaten statistisch gesehen. Man
wahrscheinlicher ist
äh als äh äh sich anzustecken als Ungeimpfte. Jetzt werden wir sagen, oh mein Gott, was ist das? Schwächt jetzt etwa Astrasinnika, das Immunsystem so sehr, dass irgendwie man
dass der Schutz schlechter ist nach sechs Monaten als bei Ungeimpften, aber
dem ist natürlich nicht so. Also es geht jetzt auch nur um den äh erstmal um den Schutz vor Ansteckung. Äh das muss dann äh
von Anfang an da zusagen ähm aber.
Was der Effekt, also wo wodurch wohl dieser Effekt zustande kommt, ist äh dass sich äh dann einfach mit Astra Sinnika äh,
Geimpfte äh unvorsichtiger Verhalten als Ungeimpfte. Aber eben äh äh praktisch
kein Schutz durch den Impfstoff mehr vor Ansteckung haben, was dann statistisch gesehen sozusagen in einen negativen Schutz äh mündet, aber nicht weil der Impfstoff nur sagen
das Immunsystem schwächen würde, sondern weil die Leute unvorsichtiger sind so.
Ist äh das Ding, aber ähm.
Ja, also dass das vielleicht so zu den Zeitpunkten, das deckt sich natürlich jetzt nur bedingt mit den offiziellen Empfehlungen, aber tendenziell so sieht's so aus, dass eigentlich
bei den meisten Impfstoffen
äh sechs Monate schon äh zu lang sind und das nur entweder moderner oder die Astra moderner äh Kombination man sagen kann, okay, die ist für sechs Monate gut
äh alles andere äh so auch auch zweimal Biontech äh sind eigentlich sechs Monate äh schon fast zu lang. Also da sind vier bis fünf Monate eigentlich bei zwei Mal Biontech
der richtige Zeitpunkt zum Boostern. So das sind aber jetzt nur alles Mittelwerte. Und.
Es gibt noch mal dann eine andere Auswertung, nämlich äh wie sich das äh mit.
Der Altersabhängigkeit eigentlich verhält und das ist ähm auch,
interessant, weil bei den über Sechzigjährigen
sinkt interessanterweise der Schutz nicht so schnell ab wie bei jüngeren Leuten aber er ist von Anfang an nicht so gut so aber,
Mhm.
Im Prinzip bis äh ja bis fünf Monate eigentlich ist bei Älteren im im Schnitt äh äh der.
Impfschutz noch gut äh und erst so ab dann dem sechsten Monat und äh ab dem Jahr Fünften.
Immer noch bei Schutz vor Infektionen oder bei Schutz vor Tod?
Vollschutz vor Infektionen. Nur das geht jetzt nur um Schutz vor Infektionen, also die Epidemiologische Komponente. Ähm so, aber.
Kann dann sagen Schutz vor Tod. Jetzt spielt bei den Jüngeren.
Fast keine Rolle. So, da sind die Zahlen eher eher niedrig. Ähm.
Aber ja in den mittleren Altersgruppen spielt es eine Rolle, aber in Älteren.
Äh die sagen äh halbiert bis bis viertelt es äh sagen noch mal äh im Falle einer Ansteckung die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dann zu sterben. Also das waren zumindest die Zahlen, die ich gesehen habe, dass in der Altersgruppe jetzt durch die Impfungen ja äh die die Fallsterblichkeit so um,
zwei, zweieinhalb äh Faktor zurückgegangen ist. Da gibt's sicherlich noch mehr Daten, aber das ist so, dass über den Schnitt alle Impfstoffe und äh Impfquote größer 90Prozent sind das so die die Größenordnung so. Bei,
jüngeren äh so.
Ist äh der Schutz von Anfang an besser, vor allem in der Altersgruppe 40 bis 59. Es ist äh wirken die Impfstoffe,
scheinbar besser als bei den 18 bis 39-jährigen und äh ja lassen aber so in beiden Altersgruppen eben schneller,
nach, so dass ähm,
eigentlich bei jünger jüngere Leute so also unter 60-jährige im Grunde genommen auch schon unabhängig vom vom Impfstoff irgendwie äh nach fünf Monaten beziehungsweise dann die.
Noch äh,
jüngeren die die 18 bis 39-jährigen auch schon eher nach vier, fünf Monaten äh sich Boostern lassen sollten, um wieder vollen Impfschutz zu kriegen.
Aber die haben natürlich eine eine deutlich geringere Wahrscheinlichkeit dann zu Schaden äh zu kommen. Insofern ist es halt bisschen kompliziert mit den, ich sage mal Boosterempfehlungen
aber tendenziell will ich sagen sind sechs Monate
eher zu lange und ähm für die für die meisten Altersgruppen und für die meisten Impfstoff
äh äh Kombination oder für die häufigste nämlich nur Biontech äh sollte man eigentlich die fünf Monate ja nicht überschreiten. Würde ich sagen aus den Zahlen äh äh die da
die da äh mir vorliegen. Ja äh.
Unterm Strich kann man aber sagen, alle sollten sich lassen. Äh egal was ist und am besten auch so früh wie möglich, weil äh ich glaube, das ist alles äh sehr vergänglich am Ende.
Lieber früher als später.
Corona war eine beinhaltet jetzt äh die Leute auch an die Buße-Impfung, wenn man seine anderen richtig eingetragen hat. Keine Ahnung, ob die.
Berücksichtigt, welche Impfstoffe hier äh rankommen. Ich schätze mal, ist einfach nur ein ganz normaler Zeitabstandscounter. Was anderes kann man nicht
erreichen. Äh die Safebag-Applikation vom PI ähm mit der man so seine Impfreaktionen äh aufzeichnen kann, kann jetzt auch die Booster-Impfung, das war am Anfang nicht so.
Da kam jetzt ein Update. Das Update hat dann allerdings gleich meine Einträge von den ersten beiden Impfungen äh gelöscht, weil warum auch immer.
Als ich dann gesagt habe, ja mir egal, dann mache ich halt Dritte. Er so, Janine, du brauchst ja erstmal die ersten beiden. Ich so, du Arsch, geile App-Entwicklung, made in Germany.
Ähm.
Umfangreiche Informationen, ich habe hier auch noch ein Video äh verlinkt, was ich jetzt nicht zusammenfassen kann, was auch nochmal Boosterimpfung, Aspekte äh all das, wo was wir gerade angesprochen haben, auch noch mal schön.
Zusammenfasst. Aber ich würde jetzt gerne auf die anstehende Impfung von Kindern kommen, denn die steht jetzt an. Die EMA,
die Impfung für mit Biontech für 5 bis 11-jährige jetzt zugelassen.
So dass es im Prinzip jetzt äh losgehen kann. Das ist ähm glaube ich am 24. November passiert und.
Das heißt, äh dass jetzt im Prinzip schon legal Kinder geimpft werden können, also nicht mehr diese ganze Off-Label-Impfung. Einzige Problem ist, dass die Zusammensetzung nochmal,
neu definiert wurde
Äh es gibt also spezielle Violen mit einer anders angerührten Impfmenge und anderen Drittkomponenten.
Wie fern das jetzt wirklich erforderlich ist. Äh oder angeraten ist oder aus anderen Gründen von Vorteil ist, weiß ich nicht. Es gibt natürlich auch schon die passenden Verschwörungstheorien, dass das ja alles nur äh von kommerziellem Interesse her geprägt ist.
Keine Ahnung, kann sein, vielleicht weiß ich nicht. Auf jeden Fall.
Das Rollout auch wieder so EU-synchronisiert und es hieß bisher halt so Mitte Dezember. Läuft jetzt wohl schon so auf dreizehnter bis fünfzehnter äh,
hinaus also am 13.12. wird wohl geliefert von Bayern weiß ich eine Ankündigung, dass sie am 15.12. offiziell damit anfangen äh wollen.
Wer Interesse hat so eine Impfung zu bekommen. Es gibt hier einen.
Portal von dem ich nicht genau weiß wer das macht. Das ist auf jeden Fall kein offizielles Ding, sondern dass einfach Leute die sich hier äh engagiert haben.
Den Zugang ermöglichten wollen, private Leute, das heißt U12-Schutz.
Punkt DE. Da kann man dann äh gegebenenfalls demnächst Informationen bekommen, wo eine Impfung für Kinder möglich ist.
Mehr kann man da glaube ich derzeit nicht zu sagen, außer dass wir der Meinung sind, dass ihr auch eure Kleinsten impfen lassen solltet, wenn ihr welche habt.
So, jetzt müssen wir aber noch mal über den äh Buchstaben, den Elefanten im Raum, den neuen haben, den neuen griechischen.
Bisschen reden, das kleine O genau äh das kleine O namens Omikron. Omikron ist.
Der Name für eine neue Variante of Concern. Das ging auch relativ schnell mit dem Konzern. Die Variante wurde in Südafrika offiziell dokumentiert.
Auch gleich wieder die ganze Welt durchgedreht ist und irgendwie Flüge aus Südafrika äh geblockt hat und sicherlich,
die Variante in Südafrika, aber es ist überhaupt nicht gesagt, dass sie aus Südafrika kommt, sondern es ist halt nur so, dass die in ihre Varianten
besser monitoren als es Europa tut. Besser als Deutschland oder was weiß ich. Auf jeden Fall sind die da ganz gut aufgestellt. Das ist so allgemein.
Das Echo, was man da gehört hat und so wurde eben diese Variante ähm ja segmentiert und vor allem analysiert.
Es gibt Thesen sehe ich da äh gerade oder
Ähm ja also eine eine Meldung, dass eigentlich eher Omikron äh aus Europa nach Südafrika äh transportiert wurde und nicht umgekehrt.
Das kann halt gut sein. Also es gibt überhaupt gar keinen Beleg dafür, dass das jetzt in Südafrika entstanden ist und ich habe schon so einiges gehört, was äh naheliegt, dass es eben.
Überhaupt nicht so ist. Ist mir auch ehrlich gesagt jetzt äh egal. Das Ding ist eh schon rum und es wird sich verbreiten, denn es ist eben extrem viel ähm.
Ansteckender. Nichts Genaues weiß man nicht, dafür ist das Ding einfach noch viel zu neu, weil es ist erst Mitte November äh entdeckt worden. B einseinsfünfzwo neun ist die offizielle Bezeichnung als Variante,
ist halt jetzt quasi der ja der Name und äh ja äh jetzt
müssen wir halt mal wieder nicht, ob jetzt nicht gerade eine Variante reinkommt, mit der alles schlimmer wird. Es gab jetzt alle möglichen Halbwahrheiten und neuen Behauptungen und Vermutungen.
Bis hin zu die verläuft ja viel milder.
Weiß man alles noch gar nicht. Dafür ist das noch viel zu neu. Äh kann sein, kann nicht sein. Wäre natürlich schön, wenn's so ist, aber ist überhaupt nicht gesagt.
Tatsache ist, dass halt Omicron eine ganz andere.
Eine ganz andere Entwicklungslinie hat in dem Gesamtbaum und extrem viel Modifikationen sowohl im Spike Protein als auch in anderen Proteinen aufweist. Bis zu 30 signifikante Änderungen.
Zehn glaube ich aufm Speck Protein alleine habe ich ja im Kopf äh.
Mhm, kann sein, weiß ich nicht genau
und sodass auch der Chef von Moderna schon gesagt hat, er rechnet also durchaus, damit das jetzt hier die Impfstoffe unter Umständen nicht ganz so stark anschlagen. Chef von Biontech
sieht es nicht ganz so schlimm. Ähm also die sind sich an der Stelle auch noch nicht so richtig einig. Ähm auf jeden Fall.
Werden auch schon verschiedene angepasste Varianten der Impfstoffe geprüft. Das ist ja das, was wir eigentlich auch schon so ein bisschen mit Delta
äh erwartet haben oder was ja generell eigentlich von Anfang an das Thema war, dass diese MRNA Impfstoffe den Vorteil haben, sehr viel schneller,
sich äh anpassen zu lassen an neue Varianten. Und es kann sein, kann auch nicht sein, aber ist jetzt auf jeden Fall im Bereich des Möglichen,
Das Omi-Cron, so die erste Variante ist, wo so eine Anpassung auch erforderlich ist.
Bis es da zum Rollout kommt, kann auch mal ein, zwei, drei Monate vergehen, aber es ist halt
relativ einfach möglich die Rezeptur des Impfstoffs anzupassen, einfach auf die neue Kodierung und
das Ding in einem sehr viel verkürzteren Verfahren dann auch in die Welt zu bringen, sodass es jetzt auch nicht ausgeschlossen ist, dass wenn um die ein größeres ähm
Drama ist, also eine größere Gefahr äh darstellt, insbesondere auch für Geimpfte darstellt, dass man äh hier nicht auch gegenhalten kann.
Ne? Also es gibt unter anderem aus Südafrika ja so die Meldung, die auch kursiert von einer
Ärztin äh dort, einer leitenden äh Ärztin, die die dort auch äh ja irgendwie in die Corona,
Bekämpfung äh mit eingebunden ist und die auch mit zu den Ersten gehörte, die das, die das da die da Alarm äh gerufen haben und,
Da gibt's jetzt äh sage mal verschiedene Berichte, aber von ihr ist, also sie wurde zitiert mit des es handele sich um einen Sturm im Wasserglas. Äh was.
Wiederum darauf basierte, dass sie halt äh bei Geimpften fast nur äh sehr leichte Verläufe äh gesehen hätte äh im,
Zusammenhang mit äh ja OmiCronn so. Äh was halt bedeuten würde, dass äh ja zwar vielleicht die,
wenn das wenn das so stimmt, dass dann äh zwar man sich leichter anstecken,
kann, äh was noch andere Gründe hat, aber wenn man geimpft ist, das halt dann zu einem äh äh sehr milden Verlauf führt, was man halt nicht weiß, beziehungsweise.
Auf ungeimpfte äh scheint es aber äh mindestens genauso heftig äh zu sagen, sondern da gibt's noch keine Zahlen, aber es füllen sich eben dort auch die Hospitaler wiederum
in äh Südafrika jetzt mit Ungeimpften, mit schweren Verläufen
mit der Omi-Kron-Variante. Also kann ich jetzt nicht sagen, dass sie jetzt sie jetzt wirklich harmlos ist. Es könnte sein und da sind natürlich jetzt die Befürchtungen wieder, oh mein Gott, wenn sich das bewahrheiten sollte, dass das bei Geimpften nur leichte Verläufe macht, dass das die
dann auch wieder nutzen könnte, um quasi es einfach laufen zu lassen, so nach dem Motto auch dann
sparen wir uns jetzt die angepasste Impfung, wenn das eh nur leichte Verläufe macht, dann lassen wir jetzt die Bevölkerung einfach mal mit durchinfizieren und dann ist auch.
Aber ja ganz so einfach ist es dann äh natürlich auch nicht und es fehlen halt noch ganz viele Zahlen. Also eigentlich müssten wir jetzt noch ein, zwei Wochen warten äh auf wirklich ja bestätigte
Ergebnisse, so sehe ich das gerade, weil im Moment äh laufen da viele Gerüchte durch die Gegen.
Ja und das ist einfach bei der Dauer der Krankheitsverläufe ähm kann man einfach jetzt so schnell noch überhaupt gar keine ähm.
Ergebnisse liefern. Ist ja auch die Frage, wie gut kann OmiCroin jetzt auch detektiert werden? Also wie sicher ist man sich denn jetzt bei den einzelnen Patienten, dass es äh OmiCront ist, ne? Also das äh
entdecken dieser Variante ist ja auch nicht so, dass jetzt ähm bei einem PCR-Test da so eine Lampe aufleuchtet mit irgendwelchen griechischen Buchstaben,
sondern
Das hatten wir auch schon mal breit diskutiert, als es um Alpha ging, also als äh die Alpha-Variante in England das erste Mal entdeckt wurde. Das war ja auch eher ein Abfallprodukt. Die PCR-Testmaschinen, die sind ja.
So, dass sie quasi mehrere Tests auf verschiedene Bereiche des Virus-Genoms.
Ne? In der Regel sind's glaube ich drei und der Alpha ist halt deshalb aufgefallen, weil eben diese konkrete Mutation dazu geführt hat, dass einer von diesen drei Tests dann nicht mehr angeschlagen hat.
Auf das S ging, genau, dass die sogenannte SGTF oder mhm.
Genau
und deswegen konnte man dann relativ schnell sehen, so Aha, wir haben jetzt auf einmal eine extrem starke Zunahme von positiven PCR-Tests, wo aber dieser eine Subtest eben nicht ausschlaggebend ist und dann hat man das eben sequenziert und hat festgestellt, aha, okay, genau, weil die Alphavariante hat genau in diesem Bereich
eben einen Ausfall und,
Deswegen ist das jetzt so quasi unsere Methode zwischen diesen Varianten zu unterscheiden. Es ist nicht so, dass dann auf einmal alles sequenziert werden würde. Und so ähnlich ist es jetzt mit OmiCron auch.
Das also auch hier die derzeit gefahrenen PCR-Tests einen entsprechenden Ausfall haben und ich glaube auch wieder in diesem selben Bereich.
Und man eben das im Vergleich zu der derzeit präsenten Delta-Variante ganz gut unterscheiden kann.
Ich habe jetzt keinen Überblick da drüber, wie oft diese PCR-Tests überhaupt angepasst werden und äh wie einheitlich die gefahren werden. Also es fahren sicherlich auch nicht alle,
quasi dasselbe Kodierungsmuster ähm wird man sehen, wie gut OmiCrohn überhaupt entdeckt werden kann und dementsprechend kann man auch eben deswegen auch noch nicht sicher sagen, OmiCronn ist
äh jetzt weniger gefährlich, weil man halt auch überhaupt nicht weiß, wer von den Leuten, die derzeit krank sind, überhaupt mit einer Omi-Kron-Variante infiziert wurden.
Also zuverlässig.
Ähm na ja, da gab's allerdings äh jetzt gerade aus der letzten Woche aus ähm ja von, ich sage mal, Frau Stahlhut.
Äh hatte darauf aufmerksam gemacht. Da gab's Zahlen. Ähm von eben diesen S äh äh äh GTF, also äh Failias aus Schleswig-Holstein.
Wo ein deutlicher Anstieg betrachtet wurde die galten aber bisher sagen immer nur indikativ für Alpha weswegen die in der offiziellen Statistik sagen als
mehr oder weniger alpha ausgewiesen sind, wo also plötzlich jetzt der der vermeintliche Anteil an Alpha äh wieder hochgeht, aber es gibt kein Alpha
Alpha ist nicht im Umlauf, ja. Also bei den Sequenzierungen gibt's kein Alpha. Das heißt, es gab dann wohl auch einen einen Rundruf
äh so an alle.
Behörden, wie gesagt, von äh guckt euch doch mal an, ob ihr irgendwie nicht vermeintlich jetzt Alpha findet, weil das äh dürfte wahrscheinlich jetzt umikron.
Sein und das ist die Situation jetzt grade, dass sagen plötzlich vermeintlich Alpha detektiert wird im,
Prozentbereich, aber äh wie gesagt, messbar. Also irgendwie äh in der Größenordnung weiß ich nicht, null Komma zwei, null Komma drei, null Komma fünf Prozent in Schleswig-Holstein ist vermutlich um Mikron.
Bereits, ja und bei den aktuellen Infektionszahlen
weiß gar nicht wie viel das letzte Woche waren in in Schleswig-Holstein, aber halt Tausende, das heißt äh können davon ausgehen, dass wir's mit äh bereits mit
zig oder hunderten von Fällen allein äh in Schleswig-Holstein mit umikron äh zu tun haben gerade.
So, also das das Ding ist rum und äh und durch.
Rum und wir werden dann auch sicherlich bald wissen, wie es sich eben auswirkt. Also inwiefern die Fälle jetzt wirklich milder sind oder nicht.
Ja. Was aber ähm.
Sich zu bestätigen scheint ist, dass es sich schneller ausbreitet, grade als ähm die Varianten in den vorherigen,
wählen, ja? Also es ist ähm äh und.
Die und eine Vermutung oder Theorie ist, dass diese Mutation auf dem auf dem S äh gehen, also auf dem Spike Rezeptor, dass die,
halt eine gute Mutation ist, die die Bindung und das Eindringen in die Zelle äh erleichtert. So also mit einer höheren Rezeptverbindung an dieser ACE2-Rezeptoren
irgendwie auch noch das das Aufschließen dann äh und das Eindringen äh äh scheint auch mit diesen mit den
um Spikes äh besser zu funktionieren, was so sagen, das heißt, wenn man das Virus kriegt
äh ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es dann äh in die Zelle äh reinkommt
ist höher und eine zweite Vermutung ist, dass es eben auch äh ja äh wie wie das in der Vergangenheit war dann auch äh sehr früh, sehr hohe äh Viruskonzentrationen erzeugt und dass diese Kombination
einfach äh ja Plus eventuell eine größere Zahl von asymptomatischen, dass das so ein bisschen die Erfolgsstrategie,
von OmiCron zu sein scheint und ähm,
Ich hatte eigentlich ursprünglich gedacht, dass ich das ungefähr so schnell ausbreiten wird wie bei den anderen Varianten, wo wir ja immer Monate Zeit hatten.
Ja zwei, drei, vier Monate bis da bis das übernommen hat aber könnte sich deutlich deutlich schneller
äh durchsetzen, so wie es jetzt aussieht. Also noch haben wir hier keine Zahl, weil wir wissen auch noch nicht, wie wohl fühlt sich denn um Mikron bei unseren Temperaturen und in unseren,
an geheizten Innenräumen und so. Das wissen wir halt alles noch nicht, aber es spricht einiges dafür ähm
dass das schneller gehen könnte als wir denken so, dass es auch in vier bis sechs Wochen äh jetzt komplett alles andere verdrängen könnte oder zumindest die Mehrzahl der Infektionen.
In innerhalb von Wochen und nicht innerhalb von Monaten OmiCron sein könnten. Aber wir werden sehen.
Genau, wir werden's sehen.
Kurzer Nachtrag noch, wir hatten letztes Mal ja über eBay McTeen äh berichtet in dem Zusammenhang hatte ich auch noch die anderen beiden ähm in Entwicklung befindlichen.
Medikamente,
erwähnt. Ich bin mir jetzt grad gar nicht so sicher, wie äh weit wir das noch ausgeführt haben. Aber was auf jeden Fall so ein bisschen die Runde macht, ist, dass Pax Luvit, das ist ähm.
Es gibt eine Neuentwicklung von Merk. Den nahm ich jetzt grad nicht äh parat habe, die aber.
Mollopierer.
Genau ähm die nicht so eine super äh Wirkung haben soll, aber Pfizer behauptet ja von Pax Luwit selber
sie da irgendwie was war das, 89 Prozent Wirkung erzielt haben bei ihren Tests.
Das muss man alles noch abwarten, ob sich das bestätigt. Auf jeden Fall äh haben Sie die Notfallzulassung in USA beantragt und gibt wohl auch schon großes Interesse in Israel da dran.
Ein gutes Zeichen, wenn Israel immer schon was macht, ne, wisst ihr?
Israel. Immer genau hingucken. Die machen sich ja nicht auch nicht alles richtig, aber die machen zumindest irgendwas.
Ja das könnt ihr natürlich insofern auch ein interessanter Schlüssel sein, wenn wir jetzt mal davon ausgehen, dass es wirklich funktioniert. Also ähm,
Anwendung ist, dass wenn jemand infiziert ist und man gibt das so nach fünf oder im Idealfall, glaube ich, sogar nach drei Tagen, dass man dann eben den Krankheitsverlauf äh erheblich reduzieren kann.
Das ist so ein Enzym, was äh dem äh das Virus in Schach hält,
Weiß nicht ganz genau, wie's jetzt auf molekularer Ebene äh funktioniert, aber zumindest äh wird das Virus wohl daran gehindert. Weitere Teile des Körpers zu infizieren. Also man verhindert sozusagen eine Verschlechterung des Zustands. Und das ist ja so das Hauptproblem.
Und sollte sich das zeigen, dass das eben auch wirklich so wirkt, dann könnte das natürlich wirklich so ein Faktor sein,
eben, obwohl man dann eben mit der Impfung alles eben nur in einem bestimmten Rahmen in Grenzen halten kann, der dann eben auch noch die besonders negativen Auswirkungen der Krankheit dann in Schach hält.
Frage ich mich natürlich, ob die ganzen Ungeimpften, Superschwurbler
nachdem sie schon was gegen die Impfung hatten, auch was dagegen haben. Das passende Medikament zu bekommen, wenn sie da am Leiden sind. Das wird sich dann äh zeigen, aber ich bin mir sicher, dass sie sich das dann alles ganz genau vorher angeschaut haben.
Ja, also es ist, ich meine, Pax äh Lowit ist halt auch äh so ein so ein Prothease äh hemmer, der halt auch verhindert, dass äh halt äh ein äh wichtiges Enzym äh nicht hergestellt.
Werden kann ähm was für die Vermehrung des Virus wichtig ist so.
Mhm. Genau das.
Äh ja genau und.
Was aber das Problem bei bei PAX Lovid beziehungsweise ist halt ein Kombinations äh äh Wirkstoff äh meine ich müssten's zwei Wirkstoffe sein, weil äh der.
Äh sagen eigentliche Wirkstoff, der eigentliche Prothease-Hemmer äh wird, wenn man ihn wohl nur gibt äh sehr schnell wieder aus dem Körper entfernt, der hält sich halt nicht lange genug und deswegen
dann noch irgendwie ein zweites Medikament dazu
äh den Körper daran hindert äh äh den Prothese-Hemmer äh äh zu schnell äh äh zu zerlegen oder aus dem Körper zu befördern, sodass so ein bisschen vielleicht Hintergrund.
Auch zu äh diesem Pax Slovit.
Wir behalten das auf jeden Fall im Auge.
Aber sich hier im Übrigen äh in dem Artikel auch noch gesehen habe äh was mir auch nicht äh klar war ist.
Dass äh das Bundesgesundheitsministerium für 400 Millionen Euro äh monochlonale Antikörper äh,
angeschafft hat Anfang 2021, die aber.
Alle kaum eingesetzt wurden und wahrscheinlich in die Mülltonne gewandert sind. Ich glaube nämlich nicht, dass die monoclonalen Antikörper sich ewig halten. Äh,
und 400 Millionen ist ist schon krass und das Problem war eben, dass äh halt diese monoklonalen Antikörper nur als Infusion in Krankenhäusern gegeben werden und das irgendwie sehr früh gegeben werden
muss äh und deswegen hat das halt keinen guten Absatz äh gefunden, weil es halt in der späten Phase nicht nicht nicht mehr allzu großartig hilft.
Und äh ja und halt die Krankenhäuser nicht irgendwie Leute deswegen an Tropf hängen wollten wären. Bei,
halt ähm ja können die Leute halt eine Pille äh in die Hand gedrückt kriegen. Das ist das ist vereinfacht halt. Viele Dinge äh insbesondere natürlich.
Zu einer frühen in der frühen Phase äh dann äh das zu verabreichen.
Die monoglonalen Antikörper sind natürlich auch weniger äh nützlich jetzt, weil die natürlich auch sehr viel mehr an diese Varianten angepasst sind. Das heißt in dem Moment
wir jetzt mit neuen Varianten zu tun haben geht dann die äh Wirkung äh zurück, ne? Also es ist ja damals angeschafft worden
in der Zeit als die Impfungen grade erst so richtig losging und eben mit dem Blick
auf Altersheime, dass wenn man dann Ausbruch hat, dass man dann eben diejenigen, die sich dann erst infiziert haben
damit schützen kann. Aber es war halt auch ein extrem
teures Medikament und äh die Entscheidung das dann immer zum Einsatz zu bringen, weiß ich nicht wie oft das dann halt tatsächlich stattfand, aber offensichtlich nicht ausreichend. Äh insofern ist natürlich diese Pille hier wirklich sehr viel
vielversprechender.
Ja ja äh und äh ja gut was war's dann halt bei Pax Slovied äh gibt's,
genau null veröffentlichte Forschung dazu ja also das ist sind halt nach wie vor alles.
Mitteilungen, wo wir nur hoffen können, dass sie sich auch als wahr und richtig herausstellen können, aber ich,
bleibe halt da noch erst mal verhalten äh äh skeptisch. Also ich möchte da doch gerne die Forschung äh zu sehen und
Pfizer hatte sich ja auch jetzt nicht so mit Rum bekleckert, was so äh Teile der der Impfstudien
angeht, wo dann doch äh ja äh
äh dass nicht die nicht so sorgfältig äh durchgeführt wurden äh wie man das eigentlich erwartet hätte in in in Teilen. Da gab's ja auch so einen kleinen Skandal und insofern ähm.
Ja, ja, ja. Mhm, mhm.
Weiß ich nicht mehr.
Das ist er ist vor ein paar Wochen äh äh äh gegen das halt äh durch, dass die Firma, die,
beauftragt worden ist von Pfizer, also ist das etwa Pfizer nicht nicht selbst gemacht, sondern es wird ja immer unabhängig getestet beziehungsweise die beauftragenen Firmen und da gab's dann eine Whistleblowerin, die gesagt hat äh so äh das was da gelaufen
War nicht okay.
Hotel. Das das sollten wir nochmal das sollten wir nochmal äh uns auf wieder Vorlage packen. Ist natürlich interessant.
Ja? Ich meine das betraf jetzt nicht alle Teile äh der Studien und so, aber äh Teile und da ging's dann darum, dass halt,
äh dass dass die Patienten, dass die Gruppen nicht sorgfältig ausgewählt äh wurden, dass Double Blind nicht voll eingehalten wurde und äh ja so äh andere äh Dinge, dass da halt äh geschlammt wurde einfach.
Äh bei bei der bei der Studie. Ja, ist aber auch jetzt nicht mehr wirklich erheblich, weil wir jetzt äh seitdem eben viele andere
Studien äh haben und äh äh ja äh sagen es auf diese Studien jetzt nicht mehr ankommt oder nicht es nicht mehr darauf ankommt, dass dort geschlammt, weil die Ergebnisse sich mehr oder weniger bestätigt haben, ja. Äh deswegen
ist das dann auch aber es ist hat zumindest mein Vertrauen äh nicht gerade gesteigert
äh jetzt Sachen, die jetzt Pfizer äh einfach verkündet und die nicht von dritter Seite bestätigt worden sind.
Na gut, ich meine Notfallzulassung heißt ja auch nicht, dass es irgendwie von der Presse äh zugelassen wird, sondern es geht dann halt eben einfach auch an die Behörden. Die schauen sich die Daten natürlich an, weil ohne Daten vorzulegen können sie da überhaupt nix zugelassen bekommen.
Bis es dann halt öffentlich ähm für alle zum Review,
bereitsteht, erst dann kann man natürlich jetzt wirklich da äh abschließend drüber urteilen beziehungsweise abschließend kann man erst drüber urteilen. Sollte es jetzt tatsächlich zum Einsatz kommen, ob's dann eben auch wirklich geholfen hat, ne.
Also beim Merk auch, also bei Nupiravier hatte Merk auch erstmal gesagt, okay 50 Prozent schwere äh Verläufe äh äh reduzieren, aber,
So mussten das am Ende auch äh auf 30Prozent korrigieren. Äh so nachdem sie.
Und dann ist natürlich die andere Sache ist, dass man davon ausgehen kann, dass auch äh äh beide Mittel äh potenziell äh äh Erdbrutschädigend oder Krebs äh also muttergen,
diese Stoffe sind äh in der Regel alle äh weiß nicht wie stark, aber sie sind grundsätzlich halt muttergen und bei Monopäeravia hat man das sogar bei bei Hamstern hat man halt,
Gutschäden beobachtet und äh ja insofern was das jetzt,
Menschen macht äh schwer zu sagen äh wie viele von denen dann Krebs kriegen, die damit behandelt wurden äh ob das überhaupt relevant ist, aber zumindest
das Potential besteht. Ja.
Ja, ich denke, wir sollten langsam äh zum Ende äh kommen. Vielleicht noch ein, zwei Kleinigkeiten. Ihr erinnert euch vielleicht, wir hatten hier vor ein paar Monaten auch über äh den Vogel gesprochen mit dem Namen Winfried Stöcker.
Der äh es geschafft hat.
Einerseits mal wohl früher in seinem Leben durch die Gründung eines medizinischen, biotechnischen Unternehmens äh viel Geld zu verdienen und sich mit dieser äh Kohle dann so sein eigenes Privatlabor dann äh aufgestellt hat und dann aber auch irgendwo im Osten
Einkaufszentren gekauft hat und äh unter anderem auch äh beim Flughafen in Lübeck wohl äh mitbeteiligt ist.
Der Typ hat ja dann äh groß rum posaunt, der hätte ja hier den Impf äh Stoff äh überhaupt äh erfunden und äh das System würde ihn ja nicht lassen und dann kam ganze Strobelfraktion und hat sich schon wieder beschwert und überhaupt und
äh da sieht man nochmal, wie das System hier arbeitet. Tatsache war, er hat halt einfach einen Protein-Impfstoff entwickelt. Das ist an sich erst mal kein Hexenwerk.
Das eigentliche Problem ist dann eben nachzuweisen, dass so ein Impfstoff auch wirklich funktioniert und keine Nebenwirkungen hat und diese ganzen Prozesse hielt er für vollkommen überflüssig, ist stattdessen zu RTL und äh Spiegel TV gelatscht, die irgendwie
nicht so richtig gecheckt haben, wer wo eigentlich ist und dann erstmal so äh etwas bemitleidenswürdige TV-Berichte darüber äh erstellt haben.
Er hat sich dann eine Anzeige eingefangen, weil er eben seinen Impfstoff äh also seinen proteinbasierten Impfstoff, also man züchtet sozusagen diese äh,
Proteine, die dann ähm.
Gegen also die dann sozusagen dem Körper äh das Virus gegenüber simulieren, wie ein Impfstoff eben so funktioniert. Prinzip dasselbe
Modell, was eben Nova Wachs jetzt auch schon durchgezogen hat, aber die sind natürlich durch den kompletten Prozess durchgegangen und.
Und einer von den.
Wartungsvoll darauf, dass es irgendwie ist. Chinesischer Impfstoff ist auch ein Protein-Impfstoff?
Ich glaube, sie haben die Chinesen dann auch einen Protein-Impfstoff, aber äh ja egal.
Weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Er hat also auf jeden Fall seine äh seine seine Ermittlungen zumindest schon eine Anzeige äh lief jetzt ohnehin schon gegen ihn, weil er hat ja dann auch diesen Impfstoff schon an ein paar seiner Mitarbeiter und ich glaube irgendwie in seinem Freundeskreis oder Familie sogar
verimpft und dann hat er jetzt irgendwie vor kurzem angefangen äh einfach so eine Impfaktion zu starten mit diesem Impfstoff so
Wir machen das einfach mal selber mit seiner mit seinem eigenen Impfstoff am Lübecker Flughafen, wo er eben beteiligt ist oder weiß gar nicht, ob ihm der gehört oder was.
Hat wohl auch schon 50 Leute dort geimpft.
Wie auch immer, die auf ihn gekommen sein, mögen, bis dann die Polizei kam und äh ihn ähm.
Abgeräumt hat mit seinem Projekt und jetzt hat er noch größere äh Probleme als ohnehin schon.
Ja. Ja, also.
Was soll man dazu noch sagen?
Ja, was soll man dazu sagen? Das ist vor allen Dingen, dass sich dann Leute natürlich auch finden, die sich irgendwie lieber einen völlig äh äh ja un äh getesteten
Impfstoff ähm zumal wenn du halt nur die Proteine spritzt äh so brauchst du dann auch äh wahrscheinlich,
Jahr noch noch zusätzliche Stoffe die das die das Immunsystem reizen also Adjoanzien äh so sonst wirkt das Zeugs wahrscheinlich
eher nicht oder du musst es in solchen Mengen irgendwie injizieren, dass du dann wahrscheinlich auch wieder Neben äh Wirkungen bekommst und die Frage ist dann ja auch welche Proteine.
Du dann kriegst, dass du so eine Überdose Spike Protein kann auch nicht gesund sein, ja. So ähm aber aber.
Krass so. Vor allem wird er von dieser Szene gefeiert, die dann irgendwie vorher immer äh sehr viel Zeit drauf verwendet hat, genau gegen so etwas äh zu schwadronieren.
Ja äh und natürlich und natürlich für die Leute auch, äh weil es ist äh doppelt bekloppt, weil du natürlich äh dadurch keinerlei.
Auch offizielle Bestellte. Das heißt, du giltst nicht als geimpft, wenn du dir dieses Zeugs äh da impfen äh äh lässt äh äh was auch immer da drin ist und.
Und keiner haftet dafür.
Keiner haftet dafür bei allen Schäden die du erleidest äh oder so ähm ja kannst du dich dann an äh den Herrn,
äh wenden äh nur und ähm ja äh also meine meine Vermutung ist
Äh äh dass das wahrscheinlich einfach kein allzu guter
Impfstoff, also dass dass der, wenn er überhaupt schützt äh wahrscheinlich nicht allzu viel äh äh schützen wird. Äh so. Das wäre meine wahrscheinlichste Vermutung so. Äh,
ähm gestorben zu sein scheint noch niemand von den Leuten, aber äh das äh lässt dann eher die Wahrscheinlichkeit also den Schluss zu, dass es wahrscheinlich auch nicht besondere Wirkung.
Macht das Ganze so äh oder gar nicht wirkt.
Man weiß es nicht. Kann sein, kann nicht sein.
Weil es vielleicht spritzt ja den Leuten auch äh weiß der Geier, was äh was der den Leuten da äh äh tatsächlich äh initiiert. Wer weiß, vielleicht sind's auch Placebos, ja, ja, also.
Sagt er nur, es wäre sein eigener, na ja oder er hat doch Biontech irgendwie organisiert und spritzt das und äh tut nur so als ob.
Das wäre natürlich.
Finde ich da schon diese Aktion da aus Griechenland. Hast du von der äh mitbekommen wo irgendwelche ähm,
Impfgegner sich scheinen impfen lassen wollten von äh Ärzten denen teuer Geld bezahlt haben, damit die ihn irgendwie Kochsatz äh spritzen und dann irgendwie einen Impfzertifikat ausstellen.
Ja, die Ärzte haben das Geld gerne genommen, haben die aber dann trotzdem einen richtigen Impfstoff versorgt. Grandiose Aktion.
Äh ja ich meine äh ja also ethisch ist das ich weiß nicht ob das jetzt also äh ja aber.
Ist es schwierig, aber ist trotzdem lustig. Gut ähm wir müssen Schluss machen Pavel.
Ja äh.
Äh wieder einiges durch. Ähm gäbe noch so einiges, worauf man rumhauen kann, äh aber machen wir jetzt nicht.
Ja ja kriegen wir einen optimistischen Ausblick äh zustande irgendwie gerade?
Impfpflicht könnte kommen.
Impfbereitschaft wird sich äh steigern, dadurch, dass sich leider jetzt auch die vierte Welle noch weiter steigern wird. Wir werden leider, leider sehr viele äh covid-Tote sehen in den nächsten Wochen
Weihnachten wird wieder ungemütlich. Es gibt die Einschätzung, dass wir den Höhepunkt zu Weihnachten erreichen werden mit anderen Worten es auch,
absehbar, dass wir genauso wie im letzten Jahr wieder äh Lockdown-Situationen bekommen werden. Da wird dann unter Umständen der Weihnachtsurlaub äh bei sterben so.
Leute richtig äh freuen und zurecht werden wir uns wieder über die Politik
beklagen, die alles wieder viel zu spät
gesehen hat, dann wieder total überrascht war, als Dinge eingetreten sind, die alle sechs Monate vorher schon vorhergesagt haben und auch schon eine Liste aufgestellt haben, wo drauf dann was tun müsste, damit es äh zu verhindern ist.
Diese Bereitschaft existiert einfach nicht in Deutschland. Also es ist einfach diese politische Krise, die du schon vor einem Jahr bejammert hast
die hat sich einfach so fortgesetzt und ehrlich gesagt, ich bin noch nicht davon überzeugt, dass jetzt in irgendeiner Form durch den Regierungswechsel sich da substanziell was dran ändern wird.
Also es gibt halt auch noch die eine große Wildcard, nämlich ja OmiCron, so wo wir überhaupt noch nicht richtig sagen können, äh wie sich das jetzt auswirken wird auf die Zahlen. Also es kann gut sein,
äh OmiCron äh auch nochmal eine eigene Welle macht. Ja.
Das kann in der Tat.
Ist es durchaus möglich, dass äh irgendwie äh ja äh wir wir sozusagen noch eine noch eine weitere Welle in der Welle äh kriegen jetzt äh.
Viereinhalb der Welle.
Die die Überwälle ähm.
Obertonwelle sozusagen, die.
Tonwelle OmiCronn.
Ja, also dass wir nur sagen, wenn Omikron nicht wäre, vielleicht im Januar äh fertig werden, aber durch Omikron dann vielleicht äh so äh,
die Zahlen jetzt dann runtergehen, aber wer dann im Januar nochmal wieder einen Anstieg äh äh kriegen könnten, aber das weiß äh im Moment äh eigentlich kein Mensch äh so was das bedeuten äh wird, aber ja.
Also so richtig irgendwie gerade äh so äh fällt mir nichts wirklich allzu Optimistisches ein.
Dann bemühen wir uns jetzt auch nicht groß was zu äh finden das ist. Es ist wie es ist. Ihr wisst ja äh wie es ist und ähm irgendwie kommen wir dann aber doch äh schon durch. Wie sagt's du so schön?
Letztes Mal die meisten von uns werden's überleben.
Die meisten werden's ja, ja, das ist äh sozusagen, ja.
Äh uns am Ende immer.
Nach wie vor ja, das ist sozusagen der der kleinste äh äh Nenner, aber na ja gut. Ausland.
Ja, okay.
Ja, ja, nee, Ausland haben wir diesmal diesmal weggelassen und ein Welt äh äh so, aber äh sieht anderswo jetzt sieht äh sieht in den meisten äh Ländern um uns herum äh.
Auch ziemlich scheiße aus grade, vielleicht noch, um das noch am Ende. Äh.
Woanders ist auch scheiße.
Woanders ist auch schlecht.
Das werden wir dann äh nächsten Mal aufgreifen. Jetzt müssen wir erstmal diese Themen wegkriegen. Jetzt sagen wir tschüss, wir sind schon viel zu lange.
Macht's gut, tschau.